Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Brittlaff und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 142 von UKW.
Und ja, heute, wie nicht überraschend, wollen wir fortführen unsere Erzählung
vom Krieg in der Ukraine mit mir und mit Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo.
Letzte Sendung war vom 9. Januar 2026, das Datum heute ist der 18.
Februar, sind also ungefähr fünf Wochen vergangen seit der letzten Sendung.
Fünf, sechs Wochen. Genau, und wir hatten uns ein bisschen mal auf die internationale
politische Lage begeben und so ein bisschen ausgegrätscht und die Situation
in Venezuela aufgegriffen,
auch ein bisschen was über Ukraine.
Wir wollen heute auch das Venezuela-Thema noch mal kurz aufnehmen.
Aber im Wesentlichen geht es dann doch wieder um die Situation in der Ukraine
und auch um die gesamte internationale politische Situation rund um den Krieg
und was das so mit uns und mit der NATO und mit den USA macht.
Denn es ist ja wieder eine Menge passiert, kann man sagen.
Ja, ein bisschen.
Ja, ich würde sagen, legen wir doch mal gleich los und knüpfen wir mal an das
an, was wir letztes Mal halt besprochen haben.
Also USA ist in Venezuela einmarschiert, kann man jetzt gar nicht sagen.
Eingeflogen, hat sich den Maduro geschnappt, in Fesseln gesetzt und in die USA
deportiert und dort ins Gefängnis geworfen.
Und ich meine, wir hatten ja auch letztes Mal schon so ein bisschen daran gezweifelt, was...
Ob sozusagen die postulierten Ziele hier überhaupt erreicht werden.
So Behauptungen mit die USA würden jetzt hier den Ton angeben in Venezuela.
Naja, also der Fallout ist irgendwie erwartbar.
Eigentlich in meiner Wahrnehmung hat die USA jetzt einfach so eine fortgesetzte
Erpresserrolle übernommen, weil abgesehen davon, dass sie eben den Maduro geschnappt
haben, ist die einzige wirkliche Maßnahme die,
dass sie ein Embargo des Öltransfers von Venezuela irgendwie eigenmächtig eingeleitet haben.
Es werden Tanker abgefangen.
Das wirkt alles ein bisschen random und auch sehr fishy, weil es halt berichtet
wird, dass die Tanker dann einfach so hops nehmen, die aus Venezuela ablegen.
Dorthin fahren und wenn die dann irgendwelches Öl haben, wird das irgendwie
verkauft und das Geld geht wahrscheinlich bei Trump irgendwo in den Katar-Bank-Account.
Das ist also alles auch hochgradig illegal. Ja.
Ja und ansonsten passiert eigentlich gar nichts in Venezuela.
Es hat nur so die Folge, dass irgendwie Kuba jetzt hinten überfällt.
Ja, wobei ich auch gehört habe, dass die Transporte in die USA zugenommen haben
von venezuelanischem Öl massiv.
Also es scheint so, dass irgendwie die Venezuelaner jetzt ihr Öl nur noch in
die USA karren dürfen im Prinzip und das auch tun und alles andere wird halt unterbunden.
So sieht das gerade aus.
Genau und kein Regime-Change, also nicht im Sinne von es gibt jetzt ein anderes Regime,
sondern mehr so ein Regime-Change im Sinne, wir changen das Regime jetzt einfach
nur dahingehend, dass einfach das Öl jetzt zu uns gefahren wird,
wahrscheinlich für irgendeinen erpresserisch niedrigen Betrag.
Wer auch immer daran unterm Strich wirklich verdient, aber das venezolanische
Volk bestimmt gar nicht.
Und wir hatten das ja auch schon erwähnt. Es macht ja Sinn,
also Sinn in Anführungsstrichen, aus der USA-Perspektive, denn an der Südküste
der USA stehen eine ganze Menge Raffinerien,
die tatsächlich auf diese Art von Öl, die in Venezuela gehoben wird, angepasst sind.
Und die eigentlich ein bisschen unterversorgt waren. In anderen Worten,
die USA haben da erschlagen sozusagen mehrere Fliegen mit einer Klappe,
sie klauen sozusagen venezolanisches Öl und verdienen da dran und nebenbei werden
dann auch noch die ganzen Raffinerien, die zu wenig zu tun gehabt haben,
wieder in Betrieb genommen oder hochgefahren.
Sodass sie dann darüber ihr Geld machen können auf Kosten von Venezuela.
Und aber natürlich auch auf Kosten von Kuba, denn es gibt jetzt keine Lieferungen
mehr nach Kuba und den Kubanern geht das Öl aus so sehr,
dass sie jetzt den Flugverkehr weitgehend haben einstellen müssen,
weil sie einfach kein Kerosin mehr haben.
Das ist natürlich ein Riesenproblem für das Land, was zum Guteil auch vom Tourismus lebt.
Wahrscheinlich vor allem viel von russischen Touristen, aber auch nicht nur.
Es gibt ja riesige Touristengebiete in Kuba, also wirklich High Class, Luxus, Strandebenen.
Ich war ja mal da, das ist einfach unfassbar.
Es gibt eine riesige Tourismusinfrastruktur, die so ein bisschen entkoppelt
ist vom normalen Leben in Kuba.
Also man kann überall hingehen, oder konnte ich zumindest damals,
aber wenn du dann halt so von dem einen in den anderen Bereich wechselst,
merkst du eben schon gleich, dass da eine ganz andere Welt ist.
Und dieser Tourismus, der dürfte jetzt so nicht mehr stattfinden können,
abgesehen davon, dass das Land Probleme haben dürfte jetzt überhaupt,
Lebensmittel und andere wichtige Dinge, die das Land braucht, ins Land zu bekommen.
Mexiko, die Frau Scheinbaum, die scheint ja alle beisammen zu haben,
die hat angekündigt, dass sie Versorgungsflüge, also humanitäre Hilfe nach Mexiko
auf jeden Fall ermöglichen wird.
Mexiko und Kuba hatten eigentlich immer schon ein ganz gutes Verhältnis so miteinander.
Da muss man mal schauen, was daraus jetzt wird. Aber mich würde es nicht wundern,
wenn wir in absehbarer Zeit eine Kuba-Krise sehen werden, wenn sie nicht schon
längst da ist und wir sie bloß noch nicht ausreichend wahrnehmen.
Ja, ich hatte allerdings auch gehört, dass Mexiko auch Öllieferungen vornimmt an Kuba.
Und auch die jetzt sogar mit Zustimmung der USA ausgeweitet hat.
Also die USA ist wohl noch nicht so weit, dass sie das Regime zum kompletten
Zusammenbruch bringen.
Wollen.
Deswegen wollen nur, dass sie zwar massive Schmerzen spüren,
aber nicht, dass dort jetzt plötzlich eine humanitäre Katastrophe entsteht. Also noch nicht.
Und das zweite Ding ist, dass,
Und Mexiko auch Öl liefert im Austausch für 5000 kubanische Ärzte,
die in Mexiko tätig sind.
Wobei diese kubanischen Ärzte halt Mexiko nicht bezahlt, sondern,
ja keine Ahnung, die kriegen wahrscheinlich Kost und Logis frei und verdienen
dann, was so ein Arzt in Kuba verdient, Wahrscheinlich nichts,
aber die, sozusagen Mexiko, bezahlt dann eben in Devisen oder in Öl für die
Dienste dieser 5000 Ärzte.
Das ist halt so ein, wohl auch ein Ding, was da abläuft.
Aber das ist nichts Neues, also dieses Kuba, Kuba war schon immer so ein bisschen
so ein Ärzte-Export-Land und auch nach.
Und Sicherheitskräfte. Also ganz viele Diktatoren haben sich so kubanische Leibgarden
geholt in Afrika und auch Vinicius Maduro hatte ja auch eine kubanische Leibgarde,
wobei die Tatsache, dass die halt so einfach ausgeschaltet wurde von den Amerikanern,
da wurden ja, ich glaube 60 Kubaner wurden getötet bei der Maduro-Entführung.
Und das war nicht gut fürs Geschäft,
wenn du einfach mit 60 Mann nicht verhindern kannst, dass derjenige,
den du bewachen sollst, entführt wird.
Das ist also auch nicht gut für kubanischen Sicherheitsexport, sage ich mal.
Also ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen skeptisch mit diesen 5000,
weil da finde ich jetzt auch schon eine sehr alte Meldung, wo diese Zahl auftaucht.
Also Ärzteexport ist aber eine Einnahmequelle für Kuba schon immer gewesen und
auch zwischen Mexiko und Kuba gab es das schon seit längerem.
Ja, ich hatte jetzt nicht gesagt, dass das jetzt was Neues ist,
sondern dass das mit aber auch ein Grund ist, warum jetzt Öl und Geld quasi nach Kuba.
Achso, ja, ja, okay. Na gut, aber Mexiko und Kuba konnten schon immer gut miteinander.
Wir erinnern uns, Fidel Castro ist ja seinerzeit von Mexiko aus aufgebrochen
und hat die kubanische Revolution dort entfacht.
Also das ist auch ein bisschen so Teil des Mythos.
Und also Mexiko und Kuba waren nie besonders verfeindet, auch wenn sie vielleicht
nicht immer denselben Weg gegangen sind.
Naja, egal, da müssen wir glaube ich mal eine eigene Sendung zu machen.
Ja, ich wusste das vorher nicht, ich habe das erst kürzlich erfahren,
dass sozusagen diese 5000 Ärzte dort quasi in Leibeigenschaft oder wie auch immer unbezahlt.
Naja, die sind schon bezahlt. Also Mexiko zahlt dafür, auch in Brasilien gibt es es schon so.
Also es sind eher so Leiharbeiter, die dann also wirklich relativ gut bezahlen.
Relativ gut bezahlt werden. Also das, dazu muss man wissen, Kuba so arm das
Land auch ist, ist, was die Ausbildung betrifft, wirklich hervorragend.
Also die Universitäten und so weiter, das war schon, also Bildung war schon
immer ein Fokus des Castro-Systems.
Ja, also auch wenn er ja im Westen und im Kapitalismus so verschrien ist,
weil er ja Sozialist ist, Der hat ja nun wirklich auch eine soziale Agenda immer gehabt.
Natürlich, wie das immer mit solchen Diktaturen ist.
Machtauswüchse führen zu politischer Unterdrückung und Paranoia und so weiter
und Meinungsfreiheit ist natürlich auch in Kuba so nicht gegeben,
wie wir das gewohnt sind,
nur das ist halt ein diktatorisches, sozialistisches System,
was zumindest immer verhindert hat, dass sich Slums bilden und was immer für
eine sehr gute Bildung gesorgt hat. In Kuba können alle lesen und schreiben.
Und dass sie so viele Ärzte exportieren können, liegt daran,
dass sie eben so gute medizinische Fakultäten haben und es ist auch nicht nur
auf den medizinischen Teil beschränkt.
Also das war schon immer so ein Feature von Kuba, aber jetzt kommen wir schon
wieder komplett in so einen anderen Bereich.
Ja, um das noch abzuschließen, was ich auch gehört habe,
dass aber auch massiv gerade das kubanische Gesundheitssystem Probleme hat,
vor allem weil es an Medikamenten und Material und Gerätschaften mangelt.
Einfach, also die Ausstattung ist einfach, Ausrüstung ist schlecht.
Die sind zwar qualifiziert, aber haben nichts irgendwie.
Keine Mittel, ja genau.
Nicht die richtigen Mittel und Tools und Medikamente und so weiter.
Genau, aber das liegt im Wesentlichen an dem Embargo der Amerikaner.
Also es ist vor allem die USA, die Kuba klein hält und möchte,
dass das System scheitert.
Das Land ist denen halt, die Leute, ist den USA schon immer scheißegal gewesen.
Und ja, das wird jetzt nochmal ganz interessant sein, wie sich das jetzt weiterentwickelt.
Okay, gut. Kommen wir in kältere Regionen.
Ja, kaum war also diese Venezuela-Geschichte erst mal vom Nachrichtentisch,
ging es weiter mit einem alten Klassiker aus dem letzten Jahr,
nämlich Trump, der der Meinung ist, Grönland müsste ja eigentlich zu den USA gehören.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll, aber es war dann sehr interessant zu sehen,
wie im Rahmen seiner diffusen Forderungen und Vorstellungen,
was denn jetzt sozusagen mit Grönland sei,
Trump dafür gesorgt hat, dass die Europäer natürlich wieder mal zusammengezuckt
sind, aber dann nicht nur zusammengezuckt, sondern auch ein bisschen zusammengekommen sind.
Es kam dann relativ schnell, relativ klare politische Bekenntnisse, nicht nur von Dänemark,
sondern eigentlich von allen europäischen Nationen, der EU natürlich und vor
allem auch von Frankreich.
Die glaube ich sowieso gerade dabei sind in Europa ihre Rolle nochmal neu zu
definieren, so als Schutzmacht,
und ja, im Laufe dessen, dieser ganzen Debatte wurde dann der Druck doch relativ
groß, sodass dann bei dem,
Economic Forum in Davos, was dann stattfand, Ende Januar,
es dann doch ein paar sehr interessante Debattenbeiträge zu dem Thema gab.
Trump selber war dann schon so weit, ich würde nicht sagen in die Ecke gedrängt
worden, aber hat zumindest so viel Gegenwind bekommen, dass er dort ankündigen
musste, dass er ja nicht vorhabe,
jetzt militärisch in Grönland einzufallen, was ein bisschen absurd ist,
weil die haben ja sowieso eine Militärbasis in Grönland.
Also sie haben jetzt nicht vor, militärisch Grönland zu annektieren,
aber so richtig abweichen von seinen Forderungen wollte er irgendwie auch nicht.
Man weiß ja sowieso immer nicht so genau, was er jetzt eigentlich gerade erzählt
und ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher, ob er das immer so genau weiß,
was er da gerade so erzählt.
Aber viel interessanter waren so die politischen Beiträge auf der Veranstaltung
von anderen politischen Führern.
Hast du die Rede von dem Kani, dem kanadischen Premierminister gehört?
Ja, das war eine sehr beeindruckende Rede.
Also der hat da kein Blatt vor den Mund genommen, hatte man das Gefühl,
hat halt dann schon relativ klar gesagt, wie es ist.
Und so ein paar Dinge, das ist jetzt schon Wochen her, dass ich die gehört habe,
aber so ein paar Dinge sind mir trotzdem im Gedächtnis haften geblieben.
Unter anderem fand ich es sehr bemerkenswert, wie er die vergangene Weltordnung beschrieben hat.
So also quasi die usa die dann ja für im grunde genommen für,
Recht und offenen Handel und so weiter zwar eingetreten ist, aber alle wussten,
dass es jetzt auch nicht perfekt war und dass man der USA einfach hat vieles durchgehen lassen.
Also das hat er halt auch gesagt und niemand hat halt dann so richtig also ja,
wie gesagt, man hat es der USA durchgehen lassen,
nicht alle Länder, aber viele Länder, was weiß ich.
Die Nummer mit Irak zum Beispiel, der Einmarsch dort und so,
aber eben auch andere Dinge,
also wo die USA ganz klar gegen Menschenrechte verstoßen hat im Krieg gegen
Terror und Guantanamo Bay und so weiter,
wo eigentlich man die USA den eigentlichen,
den Maßstäben und das, was sie von anderen eigentlich verlangt und immer propagiert
hat, selber nicht gerecht geworden ist.
Und nicht nur das, sondern, naja, es gab eigentlich auch immer so eine Tendenz,
so Europa so ein bisschen niederzuhalten, mal mehr, mal weniger so.
Aber es gab da auch eine gewisse Tendenz, um ein starkes Europa oder Europa
nicht zu stark werden zu lassen, damit es den nicht zu sehr nervt.
Gleichzeitig hat man natürlich sich darüber beschwert, dass die Europäer nicht
genug für Rüstung ausgeben.
Also diese Schizophrenie war halt da.
Und da hat Kani halt gesagt, ja, früher war jetzt auch nicht alles perfekt so.
Aber weil die USA im Großen und Ganzen eben dann berechenbar war und eben sich nicht so verhalten hat,
wie sie sich jetzt verhält,
dass sie halt ein verlässlicher Partner war, aber nicht mehr.
So, also er hat halt ganz klar gesagt, ja, nee, also die alte Ordnung ist nicht mehr.
Also er war der Erste, der halt ganz klar gesagt hat, okay,
Und es ist nicht mehr so, wie es war und es wird auch nicht mehr so, wie es war.
Und damit sollten wir uns jetzt alle mal schnellstmöglich abfinden und entsprechend reagieren.
Ja, was hast du dir noch gemerkt aus der Rede?
Ja, ich fand es vor allem bemerkenswert, dass er erstmal sehr klar analysiert hat,
dass es sich hierbei nicht um eine irgendwie, also er hat ja das Wort Rupture
benutzt, also er hat das Verhältnis als komplett zerstört beschrieben,
also ein Riss, der sozusagen hier durch diese alte Konstellation durchgeht und
dass es jetzt eben erforderlich ist, neue Allianzen aufzubauen.
Und er sprach ja explizit von den Mittelmächten, sag ich mal.
Also er hat klar gesagt, okay, wir haben jetzt hier eine Welt,
die großen Machtzentren, er hat ja die USA niemals beim Namen genannt und Trump auch nicht erwähnt.
Soweit ich mich erinnern kann, du hast es jetzt so dargestellt,
dass er alles Mögliche beschrieben hat, das wird schon etwas konkreter gewesen sein,
aber auf jeden Fall hat er nicht über Trump gesprochen, weil man muss ja auch
sagen Trump ist sicherlich jetzt der Auslöser,
Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass er jetzt alleine handelt, sondern es ist ja eben
ein großer Teil der Gesellschaft und vor allem ein großer Teil des politischen
Systems, die ihn gewähren lassen und das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Ja, es ist ein Systemversagen, ja.
Genau, es ist ein Systemversagen und das kann ja noch sehr viel weitergehen,
die Systemversagen, da sind wir glaube ich irgendwie erst nur am Anfang,
muss man mal schauen, wie sich das so gegen Ende des Jahres anfühlt.
Aber er sagte dann eben auch, ja aber es gibt eben auch nicht nur diese drei,
ich weiß nicht, ob er eine Zahl genannt hat oder es gibt nicht nur diese Großmächte,
im Prinzip reden wir ja nur von USA und China und Russland nur so auf dem Papier,
weil irgendwie Atomwaffen, aber eigentlich ist ja Russland wirtschaftlich irrelevant.
Und wird auch noch immer irrelevanter, werden wir auch nochmal drüber sprechen heute.
Also im Wesentlichen haben wir jetzt dieses bipolare System China-USA,
das sind so die Großmächte mit den Waffen und mit dem Einfluss und der Wirtschaftskraft
und alle anderen sind halt irgendwie unter Fernerliefen.
Aber es ist ja auch klar, es gibt halt hier eine potenzielle Allianz der Mittelmächte.
Und wenn man sich halt so anschaut, so Frankreich, Großbritannien,
Deutschland, also viele europäische Länder, aber eben auch nicht nur das,
aber alles, was sozusagen hinter den USA und China kommt in der Wirtschaftskraft,
wenn die sich zusammentun,
dann ist das auf jeden Fall auch eine Stimme.
Und ich glaube, das war so ein bisschen sein Entwurf für die Welt.
So nach dem Motto, okay, ihr Großmächte, ihr wollt jetzt hier irgendwie einen
Dicken machen und euch überall auf Platz 1 setzen,
okay, aber dann werdet ihr es jetzt einfach mit einer neuen Allianz zu tun haben.
Und das war eigentlich ein relativ klarer Aufruf.
Und ich denke, das läuft dann langfristig eben darauf hinaus,
dass wenn Europa sich neu gefunden hat.
Und es auf jeden Fall auch eine Allianz über den Teich geben wird,
der sich also auf jeden Fall Kanada natürlich anschließen wird.
Aber es gab sicherlich auch noch ein paar andere Länder, die hier mit gemeint
waren und potenziell in Frage kommen.
Vor allem natürlich so Länder wie Japan, Korea,
Und überhaupt der asiatische Raum, glaube ich, da wird es zu neuen Einigungen
kommen und wahrscheinlich auch Südamerika.
Und es ist ja auch kein Wunder, dass wir jetzt in den letzten Wochen dann auch
gesehen haben, dass die EU sich auf einmal sehr schnell einigen konnte,
nachdem das irgendwie Jahre und Jahrzehnte lang diskutiert wurde,
ein Abkommen mit Mercosur abzuschließen.
Ja, also nahezu alle großen südamerikanischen Staaten.
Ich glaube, alles sozusagen an der Ost- und Nordküste.
Ohne Venezuela, ohne Chile und so.
Und es gab jetzt auch eine Einigung mit Indien. Also das war sozusagen so ein
bisschen das, was sich dort abgezeichnet hat.
Ja, und Kanada sieht sich auch
so ein bisschen als Verbindungsglied jetzt zwischen eben Asien und Europa.
An der Stelle, weil die eben traditionell auch noch eine Menge Verbindungen
haben und ja auch ein wichtiger Rohstofflieferant sind für Asien.
Also Japan und China, glaube ich, kaufen da auch Öl ein, unter anderem.
Ja, also die Kanadier sind da bisher in ihrer Politik doch sehr, sehr klar.
Die haben zwar so ein Bundesland, was so ein bisschen von irgendeinem Mager,
Anhänger regiert wird, aber ansonsten, oder eine Provinz,
oder wie immer die Dinge in Kanada heißen, aber ansonsten oder insgesamt scheint
sich das Land sehr einig zu sein, dass man da den Amerikanern irgendwie nicht einen Millimeter,
nachgibt.
Für die Kanadier war die USA ja schon immer so ein bisschen so der verrückte Onkel.
Am Weihnachtstisch. Und es war so, ja.
Immerhin haben wir da noch eine Grenze und wir wissen, ihr habt ja eigentlich
alle eine Meise und ihr mit euren Waffen und wie die USA eben nun mal so ist.
Und wir sind halt ein bisschen anders drauf, aber es passt schon irgendwie,
wir haben irgendwie eine große Grenze und wir sprechen die gleiche Sprache.
Irgendwie müssen wir miteinander klarkommen und sind halt auch irgendwie miteinander
klar gekommen. Aber seitdem Trump halt irgendwie dieses Ding mit dem 51.
Bundesstaat aufgebracht hat und irgendwie ihren Ministerpräsidenten als Gouverneur
bezeichnet hat, da war das dann halt sehr schnell zu Ende.
Und die Kanadier sind jetzt auf eine Art und Weise beleidigt,
das haben glaube ich die Amerikaner auch noch nicht so richtig begriffen,
dass das einfach ein Fehler war,
der bei den Kanadiern eine Dimension hat, die dazu führen wird,
dass einfach dieses alte Verhältnis sich so zumindest auf absehbare Zeit nicht
wieder herstellen lassen wird.
Und deswegen werden sich die Kanadier jetzt eben in den Rest der Welt orientieren
und das tun sie ja auch schon, insbesondere eben EU.
Man muss auch sagen, Kanada ist ja auch ohnehin schon immer sehr mit Europa verbunden gewesen.
Ja, also so ESA und solche europäischen Institutionen, man kann da auch immer schon mit assoziiert.
Deswegen wird das jetzt eher noch weiter zunehmen.
Und Sie sind ja jetzt das erste nicht-europäische Mitglied der Rüstungsbeschaffungsinitiative
der europäischen Institutionen.
Naja gut, vielleicht Davos, es hat jetzt nicht nur Kani gesprochen,
da kommen ja viele Führer zur Welt, auch dieser Gary Newsom hat da ordentlich
Welle gemacht, das ist ja der Gouverneur von Kalifornien, der derzeit in den
USA glaube ich am lautesten und am humorvollsten gegen Trump vorgeht.
Aber Pistorius hat auch eine Rede gehalten, unser Außenminister,
unser Verteidigungsminister, Entschuldigung.
Nicht Davos, das war auf dem MSC jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob der in Davos Achso, okay, MSC, genau,
Aber ja.
Davos Ja, den MSC, der war jetzt erst vor kurzem, aber den kann man in dem Kontext
natürlich auch nochmal nennen, also während jetzt in Davos es die ganze Zeit
um diese Grönland-Debatte ging, was alles irgendwie überdeckt hat,
aber Ukraine dort keine Rolle spielte.
Wird es nicht Davos ausgesprochen eigentlich im Deutschen oder im Schweizerischen.
Keine Ahnung. Jeder weiß, was gemeint ist. Ich kenne es als Davos. Davos.
Aber vielleicht ist Davos schweizerisch. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich entschuldige mich bei allen Schweizern,
wenn ich alles falsch gemacht habe.
Aber das ist eigentlich im Französischen. Das ist Kanton Graubünden.
Wie auch immer. Jetzt war aber der MSC, also der Munich Security Conference,
die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz, die ist ja eine der renommiertesten und wichtigsten
internationalen Konferenzen für internationale Sicherheitspolitik.
Vielleicht sogar die wichtigste, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Die war jetzt erst vor wenigen Tagen und dort sind eigentlich die Debatten dann
weg von Grönland hin zur Ukraine gegangen, auch wenn natürlich das Verhältnis USA,
Europa und die NATO-Frage dort auch nochmal eine Rolle gespielt haben.
Trump hat dann irgendwie nicht wie letztes Jahr seinen Vize Vance dahin geschickt,
der nur rumgeprollt hat und uns erzählt hat, dass wir keine Meinungsfreiheit haben in Europa.
Was wohl auch immer noch so ein Echo war, was alle im Ohr hatten.
Und das wollten sie nicht nochmal hören.
Deswegen hat er dann irgendwie den Rubio, den Außenminister,
geschickt, der zwar am Ende auch irgendwie nichts Sinnvolles gesagt hat,
aber zumindest irgendwie den diplomatischen Ton getroffen hat,
was die allgemeinen Höflichkeitsfloskeln betraf.
Dafür hat er dann auch schon eine Standing Ovation bekommen.
Das war aber, glaube ich, auch eher nur so eine, keine Ahnung,
was das war, aber eher so eine Schockreaktion.
Interessanter war aber dann, dass eben auch Merz und dann eben auch Pistorius
dort gesprochen haben, was hast du denn davon mitgenommen?
Also erstmal fand ich es interessant, dass man,
sich von europäischer Seite der Ton etwas verschärft hatte gegenüber jetzt Davos.
Also Davos war halt Kani derjenige,
der dort am meisten Furore gemacht hat mit seiner Rede, Also am meisten Klartext geredet hat,
während es in München jetzt auf der Sicherheitskonferenz war es halt dann mehr Merz auch.
Ursula von der Leyen hat halt in beiden Zusammenhängen von Europa geredet.
Da war sie in Davos noch eher so, hatte ich das Gefühl, auch zurückhaltender.
Und ich meine gut, wenn man für ganz Europa redet, kann man wahrscheinlich nicht
ganz so scharfe Töne anschlagen.
Wie wenn man für ein Land redet.
Aber diesmal hat
halt Merz irgendwie klare Ansagen gemacht an die USA und eben auch rundherum
dasselbe nachvollzogen hat wie Kani erst mal.
Also gesagt hat, okay, es ist jetzt...
Es hat sich verändert, die Situation. Wir müssen uns darauf einstellen.
Es wird nicht mehr so sein, wie es mal war.
Und das fand ich ganz interessant.
Und ich glaube auch, die Zielrichtung ist so ein bisschen,
also man will die USA jetzt nicht zu offen treten, aber was jetzt als Motto
rausgegeben wurde oder rauszuhören war an Amerika, alleine schafft ihr es nicht.
Also ihr braucht uns, so wie wir euch eigentlich brauchen.
Das ist im Moment quasi die Situation, mit der man versucht,
jetzt einen kompletten Bruch zu vermeiden, weil natürlich will man sich die Türen offen lassen.
Aber es ist auch ganz klar mittlerweile, man sagt, okay, wir lassen jetzt uns
nicht so auf der Nase rumtanzen und so.
Wir haben jetzt die Schnauze voll und guckt mal lieber, wie ihr uns jetzt bei
Laune haltet, weil uns steht es jetzt hier.
Ja, also und wenn es sein muss,
dann nehmen wir die Schmerzen auch auf uns und gehen es ohne euch,
aber so, das wird für beide Seiten.
Ziemlich schmerzhaft enden. Das ist glaube ich jetzt so das,
was dort sowohl Merz als auch dann Pistorius nochmal, der auch eine ganz gute Rede gehalten hat,
so mit einem Wort hat er ein echter Ausspracheproblem, das war auch ein schwieriges
Wort und der hat seine Rede auf Englisch gehalten, Pistorius.
Und ich muss sagen,
beide fand ich jetzt nicht peinlich.
Das ist schon mal so, finde ich, viel wert, wenn man schon mal so für deutsche
Politiker, die dann so im Ausland unterwegs sind.
Aber mittlerweile, ja, leider haben sich irgendwie ja die Koordinaten irgendwie verschoben.
Ja, Merz hat ja auch gesagt, den schönen Satz, der Magerkulturkampf ist nicht unserer.
Das fand ich irgendwie mal ein ganz bemerkenswertes Statement,
dass man sich da mal von abkoppelt.
Pistorius, finde ich, ist ja sowieso seitdem der hier in der Bundespolitik waltet,
eigentlich immer sehr klar.
Und insofern eigentlich bemerkenswert, dass er in der SPD ist,
weil es jetzt nicht unbedingt das ist, was ich jetzt von der SPD in Erinnerung
behalten habe von den letzten zehn Jahren, dass man da sehr klar ist.
Ja, wie fassen wir das zusammen? Also im Prinzip kann man sagen,
die Europäer berappeln sich, es bilden sich neue Allianzen, die USA manövriert
sich in gewisser Hinsicht ins Aus.
Sie sind natürlich noch zu wichtig und man möchte sie auch irgendwie wieder
eingefangen bekommen, auch wenn glaube ich alle der Meinung sind,
dass die Chancen, dass man sie jetzt eingefangen bekommt, wenn die USA sich
nicht selbst eingefangen bekommt, relativ gering sind.
Also man hat von außen wenig Chancen, hier etwas in die richtige Richtung zu bewegen.
Das Beste, was man gerade erreichen kann, ist, dass es nicht schlimmer wird.
Und es werden am Ende die Midterms in den USA sein, die hier bestimmen,
wie es insgesamt weitergehen wird.
Und der Punkt ist, was man halt jetzt eben gesehen hat, ist,
dass es halt ein Systemversagen ist.
Und dass eben jetzt dadurch halt auch sehr viel Vertrauen verloren gegangen ist.
Und für, ich sag mal, eine Wiederannäherung oder, also erst mal, ich habe gehört, also.
Das wird Jahrzehnte oder Generationen dauern und wird also nie,
also eigentlich die Rolle, die die USA die letzten 50 Jahre gespielt haben,
werden sie die nächsten 50 Jahre nicht mehr spielen.
Das ist, glaube ich, klar.
Und was sie tun müssten, um jetzt wieder im Westen Vertrauen zu schaffen,
ist, sie müssten einfach ihr Haus aufräumen.
Sie müssten Gesetze beschließen und andere Dinge tun, Parteienfinanzierung und, und, und.
Sie müssten Verfassungsänderungen vermutlich durchführen, das oberste Gericht
reformieren und andere Dinge tun.
Und insbesondere eben auch das an den Tag gelegte kriminelle Verhalten von vielen,
seitdem Trump an der Macht ist, auch ahnen.
Das heißt, da müsste es dann auch zu einer entsprechenden strafrechtlichen Aufarbeitung
von vielen Aktionen kommen und so.
Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass all die Dinge passieren,
also dass dort genügend politischer Wille oder Empörung entsteht,
dass dort die USA sich institutionell wandeln und kulturell irgendwie wandeln,
weil das Ganze ist ja ein Problem oder ein,
Getrieben ist auch getrieben dadurch, dass die USA auf dem absteigenden Ast sind.
Also sprich relativ gesehen, einfach was Wirtschaftskraft und Einfluss und Anteil
an Bevölkerung und so weiter angeht, ist die USA einfach auf dem absteigenden Ast.
Sie haben zwar nach wie vor die Hälfte der Militärkraft der Welt ungefähr,
aber gehen auch da, fallen sie eben jetzt weiter zurück.
Also in jeder Hinsicht. Und dann
haben sie natürlich das Problem der explodierenden Staatsverschuldung,
das Problem, dass die Wirtschaft sich in einem ganz merkwürdigen Zustand befindet.
Und das ist das alte System.
Also letztlich waren die USA ja so ein weltwirtschaftstreibender Faktor durch ihren Konsum.
Die haben ja das System dadurch angeheizt, dass die Amerikaner halt doppelt
so große Kühlschränke und Autos gekauft
haben und doppelt so viel Energie verbraucht haben wir alle anderen.
Doppelt und exorbitant Geld ausgegeben haben einfach und dadurch und massiv
importiert haben natürlich und dadurch eben die Weltwirtschaft am Laufen gehalten haben,
dadurch China groß gemacht haben und eben auch insgesamt.
Ja gerade was so die Länder angeht, also in Europa mit einer etwas alternden
Gesellschaft und einer nicht so dynamischen Wirtschaft war eben auch der Verbrauch
oder der Konsum nicht so hoch.
Also irgendwas Energie angeht, so ein Deutscher konsumiert nur halb so viel
Energie wie ein Amerikaner beispielsweise im Durchschnitt.
Und wir haben aber natürlich auch extrem viel effizient produziert,
Aber gar nicht genug Verbraucher oder gar nicht genug Wachstum gehabt,
um irgendwie diese ganzen Kram, den wir produziert haben, aufzunehmen.
Und da kamen uns dann die USA zur Hilfe.
Und gleichzeitig das ganze Geld, was wir verdient haben, konnten wir ja auch nicht investieren.
Das heißt, da kamen uns die USA auch zur Hilfe, indem wir denen das dann den
Amerikanern geliehen haben, damit die unsere Waren kaufen konnten.
Und ja, alle waren glücklich.
Die Amerikaner konnten konsumieren und wir konnten Geld auf die hohe Kante legen
und hatten eben auch Beschäftigung.
Das war halt so ein bisschen der Deal.
Aber man hat halt jetzt gesehen, dass das mit der Verschulderei und mit dem
ganzen System jetzt so nicht mehr weitergeht und dass das für alle Beteiligten,
auch für die USA natürlich massive Probleme schafft.
Und nur jetzt für die USA von diesem System wegzukommen,
von der Nadel des billigen Geldes und der ausufernden Haushaltsdefizite dort
rauszukommen, ist zwar nicht unmöglich,
aber es sieht nicht gut aus für Amerika langfristig.
Ne, das denke ich auch. Und wenn vor allem ihre Kreditwürdigkeit so weit leidet,
dass sie da mal anders geratet werden und sie müssten mal zu denselben Tarifen
oder nur zu annähernd schlechteren Tarifen als jetzt und annähernd so wie der
Rest der Welt ihr Geld aufnehmen,
dann wird das sehr schnell ein großes Problem, weil die USA unheimlich viel Schulden haben.
Ja, es ist jetzt so. Ich glaube, sie müssen so ungefähr im Schnitt doppelt so
viel Zinsen zahlen für Kredite wie Deutschland.
Genau und das wird dann halt noch teurer und sie können sich halt höhere Zinsen
als die, die sie derzeit leisten,
sich nicht leisten, weil dann wird es einfach mit ihrem Budget sehr schnell sehr eng und naja,
das könnte noch interessante Auswirkungen haben und vielleicht auch wieder neue
Finanzkrisen nach sich ziehen, oder den wir dann sicherlich auch mit zu leiden
haben, aber auf jeden Fall wird die USA sehr viel mehr darunter zu leiden haben.
Ja, die ganze Verzahnung mit den USA wirtschaftlich kann eben dann auch ein Problem werden.
Ich will jetzt nicht noch mehr über die USA reden, das sind ja noch ganz andere
Themen da mit im Spiel, jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich, unsere Abhängigkeit von
dem Kreditkartensystem und all die ganzen Sachen.
Vielleicht müssen wir auch noch mal eine Sendung uns darauf konzentriert.
Ich würde sagen, wir schließen es jetzt an der Stelle erstmal ab.
Wir wollten ja eigentlich auch nur darauf hinweisen, die Debatte läuft und hat
sich jetzt an diesen beiden Veranstaltungen vor allem gezeigt.
Vielleicht noch ein Wort dazu und was mich denn zu befürchten bleibt,
ist, dass Trump dann ein wie alle Populisten so ein,
Orban oder da einen Erdogan-Pult und die Zentralbank zwingt,
die Zinsen zu senken und dadurch erstmal quasi nochmal versucht, einen Boom zu erzeugen,
der dann aber gleichzeitig natürlich die Gefahr hat, dann eine massive Inflation zu münden.
Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, in welche Richtung das jetzt gehen könnte.
Okay, gut. Machen wir da erstmal einen, vielleicht keinen Punkt,
sondern einen Komma und gehen mal auf unser eigentliches Kernthema zu,
nämlich dem Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine.
Und ja, ganz allgemein betrachtet kann man erstmal sagen, für beide sieht es nicht gut aus.
Also die Ukraine, also wir hatten jetzt nicht nur in Deutschland,
sondern vor allem auch in der Ukraine, im gesamten Kriegsgebiet,
aber auch im gesamten Gebiet der Ukraine, unheimlich niedrige Temperaturen.
Minus 10, minus 20 Grad durchgehend. Und die Russen haben extrem viel Wert darauf gelegt,
jegliche Energieproduktion und vor allem Heizproduktion in der Ukraine zu zerstören.
Also es gab einfach zahlreiche fortgesetzte Angriffe.
Und naja, weil halt, da werden wir später nochmal drüber reden,
weil halt nicht genug Luftabwehr vorhanden ist.
Auch hier steht die USA wieder im Mittelpunkt, weil sie zu langsam sind mit
Patriot-Lieferungen, obwohl die bestellt waren etc. pp.
Es also nicht genug Luftverteidigung gab, ist eben wieder sehr viel durchgegangen
und es hat halt vor allem diese ganze Energieversorgung getroffen und für die
Ukraine ist es halt einfach krass hart. Also sogar Kiew war sehr viel Licht aus, Heizung aus.
Bürgermeister Klitschko hat auch schon gesagt, so wer irgendwie die Stadt verlassen
kann, soll das doch bitte tun.
Wir sind hier nicht mehr in der Lage, genug Heizung anzubieten für viele Gebiete.
Das betraf auch nicht nur Kiew, das betraf nahezu alle Städte.
Die Stromversorgung ist im ganzen Land an vielen Stellen zusammengebrochen.
Ja, ich meine, es wird sozusagen der härteste Winter, glaube ich,
den die Ukrainer bisher so haben durchmachen müssen.
Aber ihnen bleibt natürlich wieder mal nichts anderes übrig.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass der Widerstandswille der Ukrainer wirklich gebrochen
werden kann dadurch, aber es ist halt einfach nicht gut.
Aber auch für Russland laufen die Dinge nicht besonders gut.
Wenn man jetzt mal schaut, wir hatten das ja letztes Mal auch schon angesprochen,
dass Russland einfach jetzt mehr...
Mehr Menschen schon verloren hat.
Als in jedem anderen Krieg seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Die Schätzungen sind jetzt, glaube ich, bei 1,3 Millionen, wenn ich das so richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Aber vor allem geht halt die Wirtschaft weiter in die Knie, weil einfach all
diese ganzen Faktoren jetzt zusammenkommen.
Russland muss unheimlich viel Geld investieren in diesen Krieg.
Dieses Geld kommt normalerweise von Rohstoffeinnahmen, dadurch,
dass die Ukraine ihnen die gesamte Ölproduktionsstandorte bombardiert und die
Sanktionen noch dazukommen, nimmt Russland einfach immer weniger Geld ein.
Das Defizit der russischen Wirtschaft ist glaube ich jetzt schon im Februar,
hat schon den Punkt überschritten zur Hälfte, der eigentlich für das ganze Jahr prognostiziert war.
Du meinst jetzt Haushaltsdefizit, der des Staates.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Wirtschaftsdefizit, glaube ich, hattest du gesagt.
Ja, genau, das meinte ich.
Und ja, die Ukraine wiederum, jetzt mal auf militärischer Ebene,
wird immer bestimmter, was halt jetzt diesen Abnutzungskrieg betrifft,
hat ihre Drohnenproduktion weiter enorm beschleunigt.
Und das läuft wohl mittlerweile so gut, dass sie also in der Lage sind,
über die gesamte Front den Russen so viel Ärger zu machen,
dass sie jetzt irgendwie 30.000 Tote und Schwerverletzte zählen pro Monat,
damit halt mehr als die Russen neu rekrutieren können,
sozusagen kampfunfähig macht.
Und haben auch so das Ziel ausgegeben, dass sie so in diesem Jahr irgendwann
so auf 50.000 pro Monat kommen wollen.
Und dazu muss man mal so ein bisschen verstehen,
wie das da eigentlich an der Front gerade aussieht. Ich war jetzt nicht da.
Wir ernähren uns ja auch nur aus zweiten Quellen.
Interviews, Berichten, Videoberichten, derer gibt es eine ganze Menge.
Und so wie es derzeit läuft, es gibt keine klare Frontlinie in dem Sinne,
sondern der Stand-off zwischen den Russen und den Ukrainern sieht so aus,
es gibt halt einen bestimmten Bereich, bis wohin die Russen mit ihrer Logistik
vorgerückt sind und dann beginnt die Gray-Zone.
Und diese Gray-Zone ist eine etwas unbekannte.
Undefinierter Bereich, wo eigentlich weder die Russen noch die Ukrainer in irgendeiner
Form klar unter Kontrolle sind.
Die ist aber auch nicht komplett leer, sondern die Russen schicken halt immer
wieder kleine Trupps vor,
aber auch die Ukrainer sind in diesem Bereich präsent und das ergibt teilweise
auch diese aberwitzigen Situationen, dass das also auch gar nicht,
es kann sein, dass da ukrainische Truppen irgendwo sich eingegraben haben und
von dort Operationen und Beobachtungen starten.
Während andere russische Truppenteile schon wiederum sehr viel mehr in Richtung
der ukrainischen Linien vorgekommen sind.
Also es ist sozusagen so eine Mixtur und dieser Streifen, den das betrifft über
die gesamte Frontlinie, ist irgendwo so zwischen 30 und 50 Kilometern.
Das hat auch damit zu tun, dass die Reichweite der Drohnen immer größer wird.
Man arbeitet halt jetzt mit diesen Fiber-Optics-Drohnen, also die diesen Glasfaser,
aufgewickelte Glasfaser in so einem Behälter an der Drohne dran haben und während
die Drohne fliegt, wirft sie halt diese ganze Zeit hinten Glasfaser raus,
sodass immer eine optische direkte Verbindung besteht, ohne dass das eben durch
Störungen im elektromagnetischen Spektrum beeinflusst ist.
Und davon sind so viele im Einsatz, dass, ich habe die Zahl gehört,
dass es pro Minute so drei Drohnenmissionen gibt, also drei Drohnen.
Situationen, die sozusagen durch Drohnen hervorgerufen werden, pro Minute.
Also das ist einfach ein permanentes Gewirr von Drohnen von beiden Seiten,
aber vor allem von den Ukrainern und es wird halt einfach alles angegriffen,
was irgendwie zu sehen ist.
Das heißt, werden die Soldaten angegriffen, Equipment wird angegriffen,
Motorräder, Quatz, Pferde sind dort im Einsatz. Das ist ja völlig aberwitzig.
Es gibt selten, aber immer, wenn man wieder auch mal so ein paar mechanisierte Angriffe wo also mit.
Armut Wiekels, also mit,
Immer diese englische Sprache. Gepanzerte Fahrzeuge, ganz, ganz,
ganz selten mal so Panzer, die eigentlich auch mehr zu Truppentransportern mittlerweile
ausgebaut sind und nicht wirklich jetzt so als Kampfpanzer unterwegs sind.
Das findet man immer mal wieder, dass es so einen Durchbruch gibt,
aber meistens sind es einfach kleine Trupps und kleine Vorstöße.
Und dementsprechend bewegt sich an dieser ganzen Frontlinie wenig.
Es ist schon so, dass die Russen immer mal wieder hier und da Boden gut machen,
weil die Taktik der Ukrainer ist immer,
so lange halten, bis es irgendwie zu gefährlich wird, dann taktisch zurückziehen,
aber während diese Russen diesen langsamer als Schnecke Vormarsch machen,
ihnen dabei so viel Schaden zuzufügen, wie es nur irgendwie geht.
Und die Schätzungen wie so dieses Verlustverhältnis, das geht irgendwie je nach
Region von 1 zu 10 bis 1 zu 27.
Also so ein Opfer auf der ukrainischen Seite 10 bis 27 auf der russischen Seite.
Das ist natürlich ein Verhältnis, was für die Russen eigentlich nicht ewig durchzuhalten ist.
Dennoch sind die Russen halt ja langsam auf dem Vormarsch im Großen und im Ganzen,
eben im Schneckentempo.
Und wie das halt passiert oder funktioniert ist,
sie schicken dann im Wesentlichen so einzelne Soldaten oder kleine Trupps einfach vor,
entweder zu Fuß oder mit Scootern oder manchmal auch mit Motorrädern oder anderen,
aber meistens eigentlich.
Zu Fuß und oft bei Nacht und die sollen sich dann irgendwo festsetzen.
Jetzt schafft es dann die Ukraine zwar den Großteil davon auszuschalten,
aber weiß ich nicht, denn ein oder zwei schaffen es dann irgendwo sich einzugraben.
Und Russen schicken dann so
lange irgendwie weiter Trupps, bis aus den ein oder zwei dann, weiß nicht,
zehn oder zwanzig geworden sind, die dann sich irgendwo in der Nähe von einer
ukrainischen Position plötzlich befinden.
Und irgendwann ist dann der Punkt erreicht für die Ukrainer,
wo sie einfach in ihrer Nähe sich so viele einzelne Russen eingegraben haben,
dass sie sich dann lieber zurückziehen,
als dann dort sich der Gefahr auszusitzen, überrannt zu werden.
Also auch weil die Versorgung wird dann natürlich auch immer problematischer,
wenn du dann überall um dich herum sich Russen eingegraben haben.
Aber das ist natürlich eine sehr verlustreiche Strategie, aber mittlerweile
ziehen sich dann eher zurück, wenn sie merken,
die Russendichte um uns herum ist jetzt so langsam zu groß geworden.
Das bedeutet aber auch umgekehrt, dass dann eben in der Grey Zone es jetzt gar
nicht so viele, also wenn die Russen sich festgesetzt haben,
so besonders gut ausgebaute, befestigte Stellung gibt, in denen sich die Russen dann befinden und ja,
plus dann.
Natürlich mit dem, wie du schon sagtest, der Drohnenkrieg mittlerweile,
scheint das wohl so zu sein, dass wenn die Russen jetzt die Wahl haben,
ein gepanzertes Fahrzeug anzugreifen oder irgendwie einen Drohnenpiloten zu töten,
dass sie lieber den Drohnenpiloten wählen und das gepanzerte Fahrzeug entkommen lassen.
Also so sehr, ja, es sind die Drohnen eine Bedrohung,
aber eben auch dadurch natürlich sind die Drohnenpiloten dann massiv in Gefahr.
Und was die Ukrainer dann auch tun,
ist, dass teilweise die eigentlichen Drohnenpiloten weit hinter der Front sitzen
und über mehrere Relais dann auch die eigentlichen Drohnen an der Front steuern.
Und dass dann der Start von anderen Einheiten gemacht wird und die Steuerung
oder die eigentlichen Drohnenpiloten.
Weit hinter der Front oft sind.
Aber auf der anderen Seite jetzt die Spulen mit den Glasfasern,
also für die Glasfaserdrohnen gehen,
je nach Modell, so zwischen 80 und 100 Kilometer Spulen gibt es mittlerweile.
Wobei die Standardspulen, mit denen sie meistens fliegen, sind so 25 bis 35
Kilometer Spulen, die sie draufhängen.
Aber sie können dann je nachdem unterschiedlich große Spulen einfach drunter
packen unter die Faser-Drohnen.
Das heißt, dass selbst wenn du 50 Kilometer hinter der Front bist,
bist du nicht sicher unbedingt vor FPV-Angriffen oder anderen Drohnen-Angriffen.
Ein logistisches Problem, mit dem die Ukrainer derzeit aber noch zu kämpfen
haben in dem Zusammenhang, ist, dass sie,
also ich habe so ein längeres Interview mit so einem Drohnenpiloten mir angeschaut,
der hat berichtet, dass es halt sehr schwierig derzeit sei, hier die Koordination
der Gruppen vorzunehmen.
Weil die ganzen Gruppen arbeiten halt so, klar, die sind halt irgendwelche militärischen
Strukturen, Unterstrukturen aufgeteilt,
aber dann eben auch lose über die Frontlinie verteilt und es ist eben,
gibt derzeit sozusagen noch keinen,
zumindest zum Zeitpunkt, oder das war die Aussage in diesem Interview,
dass zu dem Zeitpunkt der Betrachtung das noch nicht so gewesen sei,
dass sie das jetzt als Herausforderung verstehen.
Dass es nicht genug Koordination zwischen den einzelnen Drohnenteams gibt,
die dort arbeiten, sondern dass die alle sozusagen.
Nur aus ihrer Perspektive heraus arbeiten und keine klare, also er sprach von
No Ownership, also es sozusagen keine klare Zuteilung gibt.
Alle arbeiten auf allen Tiefen und es würde eben erforderlich sein,
jetzt hier dran zu arbeiten,
eine klarere Zuordnung zu machen, dass es halt sagt, okay, es gibt hier eine
Gruppe, die arbeitet mit den Kurzstrecken-Drohnen sozusagen,
die vielleicht eben auch nicht so viel Glasfaser an Bord haben Und wir decken
jetzt eben nur den unmittelbaren Bereich von den ersten 10 oder 20 Kilometern
von unserer Position aus.
Das hat nicht nur jetzt was mit der Reichweite der Drohnen zu tun,
das auch, also wie viel Batterie hast du da, aber auch was hast du für eine
Bewaffnung auf der Drohne.
Also Sprengstoff wird knapp, man muss auch damit haushalten und du wirst jetzt
zehn Kilometer nach vorne keine größeren Fahrzeuge oder keine größeren Waffenlager finden,
sondern das sind eben nur diese versprengten Infanterieeinheiten,
die es zu finden gilt und die dann eben angegriffen werden.
Aber um jetzt so einen Soldaten aus dem Spiel zu nehmen, brauchst du halt nicht so viel Sprengstoff.
Deswegen wäre es eben sehr viel sinnvoller, hier eine Strategie zu entwickeln,
dass man eben diesen Kurzstreckenbereich gezielt eben auch nur mit entsprechend
ausgerüsteten Drohnen bespielt und dass eine andere Gruppe mit,
oder vielleicht Teilnehmer aus derselben Gruppe, aber zumindest koordiniert
mit den anderen Gruppen,
dann eben die Drohnen mit der größeren Reichweite,
mit entsprechend größeren Batterien ausstatten, dass die eben weiter fliegen
können, dass die auch mehr mitnehmen können und dass die eben auch,
was die Sprengkraft betrifft, so es sich jetzt nicht um Überwachungsdrohnen
handelt, sondern eben um Angriffsdrohnen,
dass die auch entsprechend ausgerüstet sind, um dann eben in diesem logistischen Bereich,
also wo halt versorgt wird, wo vielleicht Fahrzeuge unterwegs sind,
Motorräder oder eben auch LKWs oder eben auch die gepanzerten Fahrzeuge aller
Art oder eben größere Waffenlager,
dass die eben dann auch entsprechend angemessen angegriffen werden können.
Also das sind so logistische Themen, die sich dort abspielen und die eben Teil
dieser strategischen Kriegsführung an der Stelle sind.
Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass es da auch sehr große Unterschiede zwischen den
einzelnen Einheiten und deren Vorgehen und Professionalität oder was auch.
Also ich glaube, da herrscht vor allem eine große Vielfalt auch, weil die...
Eben, ja, weil die offiziellen Militärstrukturen und so nicht so richtig darauf eingerichtet sind.
Also da gibt es nicht viel Traditionelles in dem Bereich und deswegen,
glaube ich, werden die auch alle sehr, sehr lose geführt und haben sehr viele Freiheiten,
sich zu organisieren und auch neue Doktrinen zu entwickeln.
Sie meinten auch, dass sich der Drohnenkampf komplett verändert hat über die letzten vier Jahre.
Am Anfang war es halt ganz anders und mittlerweile hat es sich eben wieder komplett
verändert, wie operiert wird aufgrund auch natürlich der Gegenmaßnahmen.
Auch die Russen sind dann recht gut geworden in elektronischer Kampfführung und mit Störmaßnahmen.
Aber jetzt die Fasertrohnen und FPV war halt auch am Anfang nicht so sehr komplex.
Aber was ich gesehen habe, auch wie die strukturiert sind,
ist, dass teilweise die einzelnen Trupps auch Workshops haben,
wo sie im Prinzip die Endfertigung oder die Konfiguration machen für das jeweilige
Einsatzgebiet oder den jeweiligen Einsatzzweck.
Das heißt, die kriegen die Drohnen nicht irgendwie fertig mit Batterien und so weiter,
sondern die überlegen dann so, wie viele Batterien brauchen wir jetzt für den
entsprechenden Einsatzzweck, welche Reichweite,
welches Gewicht und so weiter und konfektionieren dann entsprechend die Drohnen.
Und ja, packen dann auch unterschiedlichste Software, je nachdem drauf.
Dann, wenn es Glasfaserdrohnen sind, wie groß machen wir die Spule jetzt da
drunter für das Einsatzgebiet. Und dann scheint das halt so abzulaufen.
Also ein wichtiges Ding oder ein neuer Trend scheint jetzt so die Tiefenaufklärung zu sein.
Also im Prinzip die Versorgung der gegnerischen Truppen so weit wie möglich
im Inland schon anzugreifen.
Weil da, also im Prinzip Logistik funktioniert so,
bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt an die Grayzone, also eigentlich da,
wo die Grayzone beginnt oder die beherrschte Zone endet,
bis dahin kann man mit dem Auto hinfahren und die Sachen dann abladen quasi.
Aber dann bis zu der Stellung ist dann im Prinzip der Transport nicht möglich,
weil wohl im Prinzip eins von drei Fahrzeugen, was sich in die Zone reinwagt, wird zerstört.
Das ist ungefähr die Quote, deswegen fährt man da nicht rein.
Und beide Seiten, speziell die Ukraine-Präume.
Also von deren Seite kam das. Man versucht halt jetzt,
den Punkt, bis zu der sich Fahrzeuge des Gegners gefahrlos der Front annähern
können, möglichst weit nach hinten zu schieben.
Das heißt, es spielt halt Langstreckenaufklärung oder Langstrecken,
so 50, 60, 70 Kilometer oder so,
versucht man mittlerweile dann die Angriffe zu fahren.
Und dann mittlerweile ist auch innerhalb der Grey Zone,
es ist das Schwierigste mittlerweile jetzt den Gegner zu finden,
weil sich beide Seiten halt nämlich extrem suchen einzugraben.
Aber in dem Moment, wenn irgendwas gesichtet wird und Fahrzeuge wie gesagt fallen
halt sofort auf, aber selbst wenn irgendwo was ist,
dann ein Drohnenpilot sichtet dort was,
aber kann das nicht angreifen weil er keine Waffen hat oder auf dem Rückweg
oder so oder weil es eine Aufklärungsdrohne ist dann wird das quasi in einen
Groupchat gepackt hier an der und der Koordinate,
jetzt das und das drei russische Soldaten gesehen dann ja.
Können die anderen Einheiten oder die in der Gruppe sind, überlegen sich dann, aha,
da gibt es was zu holen und wir können da hinkommen und machen sich dann im
Prinzip auf den Weg dahin.
Also es ist ja nicht so, sagt es nicht, dass da jemand jetzt kommandiert,
greift das Ding an, sondern der eine sieht was und es wird berichtet und die anderen wissen halt,
können sie da hinkommen und greifen dann an und eventuell aber,
ja, machen sich dann vielleicht auch zu viele auf den Weg oder so.
So, aber diese lose Struktur scheint irgendwie zu funktionieren.
Die haben wir auch teilweise eben mit Gamer-Headsets und so,
sind halt dann ständig wie in so einem Gamer-Chat auch miteinander verbunden
und koordinieren dann Angriffe einfach so, wie in einem,
Computer Massive Multiplayer Computerspiel, wo die Spieler über die Welt verteilt
sind und sich dann untereinander vor Ort virtuell kämpfen.
Ist es so ähnlich? Läuft das wohl mit dort ab?
Nicht nur so ähnlich, sondern sie haben ja auch Gamer rekrutiert.
Also es sind ja auch viele, die aus diesem Bereich kommen.
Und ich glaube, sie nutzen tatsächlich auch Discord. Teilweise.
Mit Sicherheit. Also sie benutzen überhaupt sehr viele Tools.
Es gab schon immer, ich habe den Namen jetzt vergessen, so ein Online-System
zum Melden von Vorgängen.
Also wenn sie irgendwas beobachten, da gab es schon immer so eine App,
mit der sie das machen. Habe ich jetzt leider gerade vergessen.
Aber wo wir jetzt gerade schon auch an diesem Punkt sind, möchte ich nochmal
was anderes mit einschieben, was hier gut so passt. Nämlich diese ganze Gamification.
Er streckt sich auch auf die Materialbeschaffung.
Es gibt von der Ukraine eine Online-Webseite, die heißt BraveOne.
Braveone.gov.ua und das ist eine Webseite, da können wir uns nicht drauf einloggen,
kann man aufrufen, aber da kommt man nicht sehr weit, sind ein paar News-Meldungen
noch mit drauf, aber dahinter verbirgt sich so eine Art,
Military Amazon für ukrainische Soldaten.
Und das Ganze funktioniert so, dass diese Teams, die jetzt da mit Drohnen unterwegs
sind, Die machen ja nicht nur ihre Kills im Feld, sondern die nehmen das ja
auch sehr oft auf Video auf.
Die FPW-Drohnen haben sozusagen den Videostream.
Bis man irgendwo einschlägt, wird ja ohnehin aufgezeichnet.
Teilweise gibt es ja dann auch noch sogenannte Spotter-Drohnes,
die also das ganze Geschehen nochmal von einer anderen Perspektive aufnehmen
und die vielleicht ursprünglich, sagen wir mal, das Ziel auch lokalisiert haben und dann darauf warten,
dass eine FPW-Drohne direkt eben dieses Ziel reinfliegt oder eben Bomben abgeworfen werden,
je nachdem. Es gibt ja die verschiedensten Systeme.
Und dieser Videoproof kann von den Gruppen dann eingereicht werden und für sogenannte Confirmed,
ich weiß nicht, ob es so heißt, Confirmed Kills, ich glaube,
den Begriff habe ich mir jetzt gerade so ausgedacht, aber im Prinzip für bestätigte
Zerstörungen von Infrastruktur, Soldaten etc.
Kriegen diese Gruppen dann so E-Points.
Und damit belegst du quasi deine Erfolge. Und mit diesen E-Points kannst du
dann auf Brave One neues Material einkaufen.
Und das kommt dann auch sehr schnell innerhalb einer Woche direkt in deine Gruppe
rein und, also man muss natürlich vorher irgendwie registriert sein und Security
weiß nicht genau, wie es funktioniert, aber ich schätze mal darüber werden sie
sich schon ein paar Gedanken gemacht haben.
Und das ist natürlich sehr interessant, weil effizient arbeitende Teams können
hier sozusagen dann auch bevorzugt sich neues Material beschäftigen.
Wenn man also gute Strategien hat und da große Erfolge hat, dann wird man eben
auch bevorzugt beliefert mit neuem Material.
Es gibt irgendwie, glaube ich, so an die 400 verschiedene Produkte, die dort zu kaufen sind.
Also es dürfte alles Mögliche sein von, ich weiß es jetzt nicht genau,
Aber halt Drohnen aller Art, Electronic Warfare Equipment, Kameras,
keine Ahnung, alles mögliche, was man halt so braucht.
Ja genau und das führt natürlich auch zu einem interessanten Ranking,
weil natürlich dadurch auch sofort ein System existiert, dass sozusagen dem
Militär fallen gut arbeitende Gruppen,
die also in irgendeiner Form besonders gut performen oder besonders gute Strategien
haben oder beides, fallen natürlich auch sofort auf.
Also du kriegst nicht nur diese Instant Gratification als Team.
Was dich eben motiviert, das auch alles zu berichten und zu dokumentieren,
sondern Beobachter des Systems wissen natürlich auch sofort so,
ah hier, die Truppe, die arbeitet richtig gut, was macht ihr anders,
was sind eure Lösungen für die Probleme, die wir alle täglich haben etc.
Also das fand ich dann doch auch nochmal sehr bemerkenswert,
wie innovativ die Ukraine an vielen Stellen ist, um sich hier einfach erfolgreich
zu verteidigen, ist immer wieder sehr beeindruckend.
Ja, ist aber auch schon, ich sag mal, wird alles Black Mirror mäßiger.
Ja, klar.
Wenn ich sage, das ist irgendwie beeindruckend oder so,
dann spricht da keine originäre Begeisterung für Krieg und Zerstörung aus mir
heraus, sondern es ist einfach nur ein Anerkennen der Realität,
in der sich die Ukraine befindet und die halt mit den eingeschränkten Mitteln,
die sie nun mal hat, weil sie nicht die ausreichende Unterstützung erfährt,
sich einfach was einfallen lassen muss.
Und das auch tut und mittlerweile einfach mit Abstand das beste Militär der
Welt ist und allen was vormacht.
Wenn wir nachher nochmal drauf eingehen oder können wir ja vielleicht auch nochmal
kurz erwähnen, es gab ja hier so eine Militärübung mit der NATO zusammen.
Hedgehog hieß das, glaube ich, wo ukrainische Soldaten mit NATO-Truppen,
ich weiß nicht, hat das in Deutschland stattgefunden oder wo war das?
Nee, ich glaube, es war Estland oder Litauen, eines der baltischen Länder.
Okay.
Ja, also die haben also so ein gemeinsames, war das so ein virtuelles,
so ein simuliertes Manöver oder so ein richtiges Manöver?
Richtig, die haben da richtig Ukrainer mit ihren Drohnen eingeflogen und haben
halt dann dort eben richtig Übungen veranstaltet.
Also sind dann mit, ich glaube es waren zwei Bataillone,
zwei Brigaden, also mehrere tausend Soldaten jedenfalls auf NATO-Seite,
drei, viertausend oder so in der Größenordnung.
Die dann mit ihren Fahrzeugen und so weiter,
Panzern in der Gegend rumgefahren sind und dann halt ja von einem zehnköpfigen
ukrainischen Drohnenteam angegriffen worden sind.
Und mein Sinn und Zweck des Ganzen war halt zu sehen, okay, ja,
wo liegen denn eigentlich unsere Schwächen?
Und ja, die Ukrainer waren halt von der Front und haben dann wohl in dieser Übung, ich weiß nicht,
um die 30 Fahrzeuge zerstört.
Hier sind 17 gepanzerte NATO-Fahrzeuge und 30 weitere Angriffe, genau.
Also die Ukraine hatte halt dieses eine Team, 16.000 NATO-Soldaten aus zwölf Staaten waren das.
Ja, aber direkt sozusagen dort. Also auf jeden Fall stellte sich dann heraus,
dass es dann doch auf Seiten der jetzt NATO-Militärübenden erhebliche Schwächen gab.
Ab einmal, was so die Tarnung angeht, waren die Ukrainer in der Lage,
mithilfe der Drohnen zu viele Fahrzeuge und Stellungen aufzudecken?
Und anzugreifen, das war halt ein Problem.
Und dann das zweite Problem, dass sie halt eigentlich praktisch keine Drohnenabwehr
wirklich hatten oder keine funktionierende.
Das heißt das war jetzt die Situation offenbar ein bisschen ins kalte Wasser
geschmissen, so nach dem Motto, okay was passiert denn, wenn wir einfach mal,
klassisch vorgehen, wie wir das immer schon getan haben und was passiert denn
dann und dann haben sie halt gemerkt ja.
Nichts Gutes,
Ja, ich habe hier gerade noch mal ein paar Details davon aufgeholt.
Hier ist auch das System, was mir gerade nicht einfällt. Delta heißt das,
ukrainische, diese Gefechtssoftware, die sie benutzt haben und die kamen dort
auch zum Einsatz und damit haben sie halt einfach diesen NATO-Truppen schnell
da das Handwerk gelegt, weil sie halt einfach darauf nicht vorbereitet waren.
Die Liebner haben halt irgendwie ihr Material offen rumstehen lassen.
Das war alles nicht ausreichend getarnt etc.
Und die Ukrainer haben halt einen halben Tag dafür gebraucht,
um dann irgendwie mal eben so zehn Fahrzeuge zu zerstören in dieser Übung.
Aber das war am Anfang, ist das den Russen ja genauso passiert.
Im Grunde genommen am ersten und zweiten Tag.
So, ja.
Klar.
Gibt es auf jeden Fall einiges zu lernen. So,
kommen wir zurück zum Krieg selbst, denn jetzt sind ja Dinge passiert und ich
muss sagen, das hatte ich nicht auf meiner Bingo-Karte, aber es hat stattgefunden.
Es gab da sicherlich ein bisschen Vorlauf auch, die Ukrainer wussten sozusagen,
was auf sie zukommt, ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt, was ist passiert.
Kurz gesagt, Starlink wurde von SpaceX, der Firma von Elon Musk,
die das hochgezogen hat und betreibt, so veröffentlicht.
Umgestellt, dass die Russen darauf keinen Zugriff mehr haben.
Und das hatte extreme Auswirkungen,
denn auch die Russen haben in letzter Zeit Starlink immer mehr verwendet und
hatten jetzt auf einmal keinen Zugriff mehr,
denn Starlink wurde jetzt so umkonfiguriert,
dass in dieser Kampfzone oder sagen wir mal in der ganzen Ukraine, denke ich mal sogar.
Für den Betrieb von Starlink die Aufnahme des Terminals auf eine sogenannte
Whitelist erforderlich ist.
Das heißt, man muss beim ukrainischen Staat sagen,
hier, ich bin Ukrainer, ich habe hier eine legitime Anwendung oder vielleicht
auch eine militärische Anwendung für dieses Starlink Terminal. Meine ID ist sowieso.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was dann alles überprüft wird, aber ich schätze mal,
diese Überprüfung dürfte sehr nachhaltig sein.
Und nur Terminals, die eben auf dieser Whitelist stehen, dürfen in dieser Region
betrieben werden und das ist dann halt irgendwann umgeschaltet worden und von
heute auf morgen hatten die Russen keinen Zugriff mehr auf Starlink.
Und vielleicht sollte man an dieser Stelle mal kurz erklären,
was Starlink eigentlich ist, weil ich glaube nicht, dass jeder das so versteht
und vor allem, warum es so einen großen Wert hat in diesem Krieg.
Starlink ist ein Kommunikationsnetzwerk, ein satellitengestütztes Kommunikationsnetzwerk
von sehr, sehr vielen Satelliten, die permanent in einem sogenannten niedrigen
Orbit, einem Low-Earth-Orbit, Leo,
die Erde umkreisen.
Und im Gegensatz zu früheren Kommunikationssatelliten, wo man erstmal nur einen
und später dann vielleicht mal so ein paar hatte,
bezeichnet sich eben Starlink dadurch aus, dass sie einfach extrem viele haben.
Ich gucke gerade mal, was die aktuelle Zahl sei, die derzeit ...
Ich schätze um die 3000, aber ...
Ja, ich will jetzt gerade keine falsche Zahl sagen.
Werde ich wahrscheinlich tun, aber ich probiere es zu verhindern.
Im Januar 26 sind es 9.422 Satelliten.
9.000 schon?
Ja, sehr viel mehr sind geplant. Also sie wollen irgendwie bis zu 34.000 oder
so irgendwann mal hochschießen.
Das ist auch für die Astronomie nochmal ein anderes Problem.
Egal, spielt an der Stelle jetzt erstmal keine Rolle.
Das sind also vergleichsweise kleine Satelliten, die im Wesentlichen so Kommunikationsumleiter sind.
Und die vor allem eine sehr hohe Bandbreite bereitstellen und darüber hinaus
durch ihren niedrigen Orbit auch eine sehr niedrige Latenz haben.
Also Latenz ist sozusagen die eigentliche Verzögerung, die entsteht,
wenn das Signal erstmal sich durch den Raum bewegt, also von dem Terminal zum
Satelliten und von dem Satelliten wieder zu einer Basisstation,
wo es dann eben ins Internet gespeist wird.
Und da die halt nur auf ein paar hundert Kilometer hoch sind,
ist da die Verzögerung relativ gering,
während jetzt so geostationäre Satelliten, die halt 36.000 Kilometer entfernt
sind, da ganz andere Latenzen haben und auch nicht diese Kapazität haben und
schon gar nicht diese hohe Bandbreite haben.
Die fliegen mit relativ großer Geschwindigkeit um die Erde, deswegen sind sie halt nicht stationär.
Wir müssen ja sehr schnell fliegen, damit sie in diesem niedrigen Orbit die
Erde auch umrunden und nicht einfach runterfallen.
Dementsprechend kreisen, also ziehen permanent Satelliten über den Horizont
und sind immer nur für wenige Minuten wirklich auf so einer optischen Direktverbindung sichtbar.
Und diese kleinen Terminals, die Starlink rausgibt, das sind halt relativ moderne Satellitenantennen,
die halt nicht funktionieren wie so klassische Satelliten, wie man das noch
so kennt, noch so mit so einer Konzentration mit so einer Schüssel oder so,
sondern einfach so flache Platinen,
die eine Technik verwenden, nennt sich so Faced Array.
Da macht man also quasi mit so elektronisch gesteuerten Interferenzmustern sorgt
man dafür, dass das Signal in die richtige Richtung geht Und die können dann
eben dieser Bewegung der Satelliten auch schnell folgen und das funktioniert alles ziemlich gut.
Und durch diese hohe Bandbreite und durch diese niedrige Latenz ist es halt
möglich, auch so eine Realtime-Kontrolle zu machen und sehr schnell auch große
Datenmengen, sprich Videos auch durchzuleiten.
Naja, und jetzt wird ja auch klar, warum das eben beim Militär so einen großen
Wert hat, weil man da natürlich stabil, schnell, mit viel Daten kommunizieren kann.
Und die Ukrainer haben das ja relativ früh eingesetzt und die Russen sind dann
halt auch irgendwann drauf gekommen.
Und problematisch wurde es jetzt vor so ein paar Wochen, Monaten,
als die Russen angefangen haben,
nicht nur Starlink zu verwenden, um an der Front Kommunikation zu betreiben,
also sozusagen die Verbindung zwischen den einzelnen Einheiten sicherzustellen,
sondern sie haben halt auch angefangen, auf ihre Schahett-Drohnen Starlink drauf
zu packen, die dadurch halt einerseits in der Lage waren,
tief ins Land reinzufliegen, von dort auch Videobilder zu liefern und dann auch
interaktiv gesteuert zu werden.
Das heißt, es gab auf einmal eine ganz andere Dimension der Fernüberwachung
und das bedroht natürlich dann eben Patriot-Systeme etc., wertvollere Infrastruktursysteme,
die sonst eigentlich bisher recht gut geschützt waren, weil sie eben relativ
weit weg von der Frontlinie waren.
Oder sie haben auf diese Weise, glaube ich, auch einen fahrenden Zug angegriffen.
Aha. Also es gab verschiedene Vorfälle und das war schon ein ziemlicher Oh-Oh-Moment
für die Ukraine, weil das wieder so eine Eskalation der Bedrohung war,
wo sie jetzt ohne weiteres keine Abhilfe hatten.
Und ich vermute jetzt mal…,
Dass das, wenn nicht der, dann aber doch einer der Auslöser war,
dass der Druck auf Starlink so gestiegen ist,
dass sie jetzt Elon Musk hin, Elon Musk her, sich einfach nicht mehr in der
Lage sahen, den Status Quo so aufrecht zu erhalten.
Dazu muss man wissen, dass Starlink ein IPO plant, also einen Gang an die Börse
und dort eben darauf hofft, viel Geld einzunehmen, indem sie ihre Aktien verkaufen muss.
Sicherlich auch gelingen wird, aber eins will man halt nicht.
Schlechte Storys an Bord haben.
So ein IPO soll einfach nicht davon überschattet werden, dass man dann sagt,
hier mit Starlink vernichten halt die Russen gerade die Ukraine.
Also es hätte dazu führen können, sodass
dann zum Beispiel potenziell europäische Konsortien oder Investoren möglicherweise
dann einfach entweder das nicht mit vertreiben oder davon abraten oder wie auch immer.
Und eventuell dann in den USA auch zu Boykott aufrufen kommt,
weil, glaube ich, dort auch bekannt ist, dass eigentlich 80 Prozent der Amerikaner
mit der Ukraine sympathisieren.
Also von daher, ja, macht es, glaube ich, Sinn.
Also sie haben noch eine weitere Sache gemacht, also nicht nur das Whitelisting,
sondern sie hatten wohl vorher dann auch schon einen Software-Patch eingebaut,
dass alle Objekte, die sich irgendwie schneller als, ich weiß nicht, 100 kmh oder so bewegen,
also jedenfalls einen Schwellwert, dass die dann eben auch abgeschaltet wurden,
weil man dann davon ausging,
dass die sich auf einer Drohne befinden und sagen man eben generell dann dort
auch verhindern wollte, Und das, ja...
Ja, aber das ist natürlich ein schwieriger Fix, weil es natürlich auch sein
kann, dass es auf dem Auto ist und so, dass es schnell fährt etc.
Aber das war mal so ein bisschen der Quick-Fix und hat schon mal gezeigt,
dass sie da also Besorgnis zeigen.
Genau, aber jetzt diese Whitelist-Lösung hat halt dann wirklich gegriffen,
weil die Russen nicht auf dieser Whitelist waren da wollten sie aber drauf,
und dann gab es dann noch ein interessantes Nachspiel weil dann natürlich die
Russen waren natürlich irgendwie fuchsteufelswild manche haben dann gleich angefangen
ihre Starling-Antennen zu verbrennen
das ist vielleicht auch nicht so die klügste Aktion ist aber egal,
und dann gab es natürlich,
die Versuche.
Über verschiedene Kanäle diese russischen Terminals dann doch auf diese Whitelist
zu bringen. Da haben die Russen wieder mal alles probiert.
Also sie haben irgendwie ukrainische Kriegsgefangene wohl dazu gezwungen,
Angehörige zu kontaktieren, das zu machen.
Keine Ahnung, ob sie damit irgendeinen Erfolg hatten. Allerdings gab es wohl auch,
Schon die Erwartung auf der ukrainischen Seite, dass genau das passieren würde
und es sind den Russen auch eine Menge Fallen gestellt worden.
Unter anderem gab es halt Angebote mit, ja hier zahlt uns Geld,
dann packen wir euch auf die Whitelist, was die Russen ja nicht anders kennen,
als dass sie für alles bezahlen müssen.
Einfach Korruption der Standard ist im russischen Militär, die dann wohl auch
teilweise gezahlt haben.
Allerdings dann auch Koordinaten und andere Daten preisgegeben haben,
nur dass auf der anderen Seite halt gar keine Leute waren, die bereit waren,
die Russen da auf die Whitelist zu bringen, sondern die haben dann sozusagen
das gleich gemeldet und auch die Koordinaten ans Militär gemeldet.
Und das wird sicherlich nicht gut ausgegangen sein für die beteiligten Russen an der Stelle.
Und im Idealfall haben sie wahrscheinlich auch noch die Kohle kassiert.
Nicht hundertprozentig klar, ob das wirklich so genau stattgefunden hat.
Es gibt diese Erzählung, wir waren ja nicht dabei, aber es ist eigentlich auch
völlig egal, ob das stattgefunden hat oder nicht.
Es wurde auf jeden Fall dafür gesorgt, dass diese Geschichte im Umlauf ist,
was wahrscheinlich dann eine ganze Menge Ukrainer, die potenziell vielleicht
hier gewittert haben, etwas Geld zu verdienen und ihr Land zu verraten,
davon abzuhalten, das zu machen, weil sie sozusagen sofort die Geschichte gehört haben mit,
Wenn ich das hier mache, dann fliege ich irgendwie sofort auf.
Es kann halt sehr gut sein, dass der Russe, der sich hier bei mir meldet,
gar kein Russe ist, sondern dass das sozusagen auch das ukrainische Militär
ist und nur so tut, als würde hier ein Russe anfragen.
Also das ging dann in beide Richtungen. Und ja.
Ja, ich glaube, es war nicht sonderlich von Erfolg gekrönt und das bedeutet,
dass die Russen einfach keine Starlink-Antennen mehr nutzen können und damit
ein riesiges Kommunikationsproblem haben.
Denn Russland, wie auch Deutschland, hat ja kein entsprechendes System im Zugriff
und müssen sich jetzt für die Kommunikation was anderes einfallen lassen.
Da gibt es auch schon verschiedenste Lösungen. Also auf der einen Seite bauen
sie irgendwelche WiFi-Repeater-Strecken auf.
Das ist natürlich fast schon ein Rauchzeichen im Vergleich zu Starlink.
Also ich wollte noch kurz sagen zu diesen Webseiten,
was halt tatsächlich, also was Fakt ist,
ist, dass mehrere Webseiten aufgepoppt sind, die eben diese Dienste angeboten
haben und mindestens eine davon war eben diese, die das dann weitergeleitet hat.
Es gab aber sozusagen potenziell noch mehr solcher Webseiten,
manche potenziell legitim oder wirklich kriminell, möglicherweise manche auch
von Russland aufgesetzt.
Also welche Webseite jetzt eigentlich von wem genau war, weiß man nicht,
aber auf jeden Fall gab es mindestens eine davon, die einen Honeypot hat. Ja, und.
Zu den Wi-Fi-Repeatern kam dann
noch die Geschichte, die Ukrainer wussten natürlich, was passieren würde.
So die Einheiten, dass den Russen Starlink abgeschaltet wird und wussten auch
oder halt dann auch antizipiert,
was die Russen dann machen würden,
nämlich Wi-Fi-Repeater oder andere Richtfunkstrecken einfach zu errichten.
Aber was brauchst du für eine Richtfunkstrecke?
Sichtkontakt. Wie kriegst du Sichtkontakt? Du montierst deine Antennen irgendwie
hoch auf irgendwelchen existierenden Türmen oder Kränen oder Hochhäusern.
Und als die Russen dann versucht haben,
die Antennen dann dort oben anzubringen, haben dann dort schon die Drohnen auf
sie gewartet und es gibt also dann etliche Drohnenfilme,
wo dann so ein russischer Soldat, der auf einen Kran geschickt wurde oder so,
um dort was zu montieren,
dann oben auf dem Kran von einer
Drohne angegriffen wurde und
das stelle ich mir besonders unangenehm vor
so also das ist
sagen ein problem und dann ist es so dass natürlich auch irgendwie diese richtfunkstrecken
mit strom versorgen muss und wenn du die mit batterien betreibt muss dann regelmäßig
jemand hochklettern anderer nachteil ist dass die natürlich.
Anpeilbar sind oder einfacher anpeilbar sind als Starlink-Terminal,
sodass natürlich jeder auch Repeater oder Router, der dort installiert wurde,
dann auch sehr schnell Aufmerksamkeit auf sich gezogen hat.
Das heißt, das ist halt dann nur so bedingt gut gelaufen als Alternative.
Ja, sie probieren es jetzt auch mit Ballons, also sie lassen so stratosphärischen
Ballons mit 5G-Base-Stations los und versuchen darüber eine Kommunikation aufzubauen,
aber was auch immer sie sich jetzt einfallen lassen,
es ist nicht absehbar, dass sie irgendetwas aufgebaut bekommen, was auch nur im,
Ansatz, so viel Versatilität und Nützlichkeit hat für den Krieg wie Starlink.
Ja, also ich habe auch dann auch geguckt, was ist denn das Zweitbeste nach Starlink
und das ist halt so Eutelsat OneWeb mit einer Konstellation von 600 Satelliten,
also ein Zehntel davon, die dann auch noch höher fliegen und das ist auch nicht direct to consumer,
sondern die haben halt Vertriebspartner, wo du dann irgendwie,
also das ist halt in erster Linie für Unternehmen.
Und ist auch deutlich teurer, geht dann bei 1000.
Und fürs Militär, das gehört ja den Franzosen und das kommt jetzt auch in der Ukraine zum Einsatz.
Ja, ist aber von der Bandbreite her kann das überhaupt nicht mithalten.
Also es liegt dann eher so bei gleich bis 20, aber 20, 30 Megabit ist auch ganz okay.
Also bis zu 100 können die, glaube ich.
Im Bestfall, aber eher so 2030 ist wohl das, was die liefern werden.
Das habe ich jetzt gehört bei Starlink, die toppen irgendwie jetzt bei 500 Megabit
oder so aus mittlerweile.
Also die,
derzeit ist Starlink dabei, die dritte Generation von Satelliten auszurollen
und die Starlink 3 Dinger, die können nochmal extrem viel mehr.
Das geht dann schon in den Gigabit-Bereich und da hat glaube ich jeder Satellit
hat irgendwie dann schon so Terabit-Bandbreite.
Das ist total irre, was sie da machen, aber wenn ich jetzt hier eine normale
Styling-Schüssel in Deutschland in Betrieb nehme, wenn es gut läuft,
kriege ich so üblicherweise so 250 Megabit daraus.
Im Download und 100 oder vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen mehr im Uplink.
Und das mag auch schon reguliert sein, dass mir da sozusagen nicht mehr zugestanden wird.
Das hängt ja auch mal ein bisschen davon ab, wie viele andere Terminals sind
dann noch im Versorgungsbereich, was gerade die Kapazität von dem Downlink etc.,
wie sehr ist der Satellit selber gerade ausgelastet.
Aber dadurch, dass die auch so schnell über den Horizont ziehen und dann schon
wieder der nächste kommt, Also das ändert sich und die Software,
die halt diese Bandbreite verteilt, die wird auch permanent verbessert und angepasst
und sie haben ja auch diverse Updates vorgenommen in Bezug auf das Protokoll
selbst, damit sich das nicht so leicht jammen lässt.
Ja, also Starlink ist leider geil, muss man sagen.
Also Elon Musk können wir alle nicht leiden, aber was SpaceX für eine Technologie entwickelt hat,
das ist schon wirklich sehr beeindruckend und das ist total konkurrenzlos und
das wird auch noch auf absehbare Zeit total konkurrenzlos sein.
Und es kann sogar sein, dass es auf sehr, sehr, sehr lange Zeit allein schon
deshalb konkurrentlos sein wird, weil es einfach nicht nur das am besten finanzierte
System ist, spätestens jetzt mit diesem Börsengang,
sondern auch, weil sie eben diejenigen sind, die jetzt schon auch die Frequenzen
zugeteilt bekommen haben.
Und sie nutzen ja in allen Ländern unterschiedliche Frequenzen und das ist so ein Flickenteppich.
Aber andere Konstellationen wie zum Beispiel Eutelsat müssen einerseits erstmal
diese Satelliten hochbekommen, was ja SpaceX quasi auch selbst macht.
Also sie haben ja selber die Raketen und sie haben auch die besten Raketen derzeit
für solche Launches mit einer Falcon 9-Rakete schicken die,
die ich weiß nicht wie viele Starlink-Satelliten gleichzeitig immer wieder in den Orbit.
Die werden ja auch permanent gestartet.
SpaceX hat jede Woche irgendwelche Launches, das ist schon überhaupt gar keine News mehr.
Während so die Europäer es feiern, wenn sie irgendwie drei, vier,
fünf Launches pro Jahr mit ihrer Ariane 6-Rakete hinbekommen.
Also derzeit spielt Europa auch leider im Space Game wirklich nur die zweite Geige.
Die haben zwar mit der Ariane lange Zeit das zuverlässigste System gehabt,
aber sind natürlich jetzt, was SpaceX betrifft,
komplett abgehängt worden, was die Kosten vor allem betrifft,
weil durch ihre hohe Startrate und vor allem durch ihre hohe Auslastung,
Allein schon durch Starlink selbst, was ja selber wieder viel Geld verdient.
Dadurch sind sie einfach auch preislich in ganz anderen Sphären.
Und da muss halt Europa jetzt extrem nachliefern.
Lange Zeit hat man halt darauf verzichtet, der ESA Startgarantien zu geben,
mit denen sie eben überhaupt erstmal in so eine Massenproduktion kommen könnte.
Davon sind wir ja weit entfernt. Und dementsprechend wird es sehr teuer sein,
dieses Eutelsatzsystem auszubauen. Aber es wird keine Alternative dazu geben, denke ich.
Weil so wie wir mit Galileo eine GPS-Alternative gebaut haben,
brauchen wir natürlich jetzt auch so eine Internet-Alternative.
Die Chinesen sind im Übrigen auch schon mit ihrem Baidu-System unterwegs.
Also ich glaube, das ist so auch der potenzielle Kandidat 2,
den du vielleicht übersehen hast bei einer Recherche.
Wie viel haben die hier oben? Meines Wissens hatten die aber noch nichts oben so richtig oder aus?
Ja, weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Mal kurz schauen.
Nee, das ist gar nicht das Baidu. Das habe ich jetzt verwechselt.
Ja, aber das heißt, glaube ich, das heißt auch irgendwie Baidu,
die Satellitenkonstellation.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, lassen wir das mal offen, Chinesen werden definitiv hier
auch nachlegen. Sagen wir es mal so.
Und wir wissen alle, wie schnell das gerade vonstanden geht,
Wenn China was will, dann machen die das einfach und technologisch sind die
da auf jeden Fall in der Lage und bereit,
so etwas auch zu tun.
Die Russen träumen davon, sowas zu haben, haben allerdings dieses ganze Space-Programm
einstellen müssen, weil ihnen einfach die Kohle ausgegangen ist.
Und ich glaube, dass sie auch einen extremen Braindrain haben in diesem Space-Bereich,
nachdem auch alle Kooperationen ausgelaufen sind.
Noch starten sie Satelliten, noch starten sie Systeme.
Sie haben natürlich Militärsatelliten, aber sie haben halt nichts,
was auch nur ansatzweise einen Starlink-Ausfall kompensieren könnte.
Ja, also die Russen haben ja Probleme, sagen ihr GLONASS, ihre GPS-Variante,
dort die Konstellation überhaupt am Leben zu halten.
Ich habe mir das mal angeguckt und sagen, Satellit für Satellit bin ich das
mal durchgegangen, wie lange die schon oben sind.
Und ja, also die Konstellation ist ganz schön am, also es fehlen zwei Satelliten
und der Rest sieht auch nicht gut aus.
Was jetzt SpaceX angeht, bin ich mir noch nicht so sicher.
Ähm, muss ich sagen, ja, einerseits...
So mit dieser Konstellation technisch und so weiter Wahnsinn,
aber ich habe keine Geschäftszahlen gesehen, weil die sind ja nicht an der Börse
und müssen nicht allzu viel veröffentlichen.
Und die haben natürlich nicht nur eine unglaubliche Menge an Geld jetzt investiert,
um 6.000 Satelliten hochzubringen.
9.000.
9.000 Satelliten hochzubringen. Das waren mittlerweile, glaube ich,
zig Milliarden, die sie da investiert haben.
Je größer die Konstellation wird, umso mehr müssen auch noch ersetzt werden jedes Jahr.
Das heißt auch, es kommen mittlerweile über 1000 von denen pro Jahr runter.
Und das werden eher noch mehr werden. Und das heißt, nur um dann diese Konstellation
zu betreiben, musst du jedes Jahr 3000 Satelliten hochschicken.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das finanziell auf Dauer aufgehen wird.
Ja, so wie gesagt, ich habe die Zahlen nicht gesehen, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt,
hunderte Millionen von Nutzern Starlink nutzen würden, ja, so viel ist es nicht,
es sind, mögen Hunderttausende, vielleicht ein paar Millionen sein,
ja, aber von den acht Milliarden oder so,
also insofern, ich möchte, also Also ich bin gespannt, aber es ist definitiv so.
Wir sind ja auch kein Wirtschaftspodcast hier. Kurzer Nachtrag,
also das chinesische System heißt Guowang,
Und da gibt es auch schon ein paar Satelliten, die im Orbit sind,
aber so richtig im Betrieb ist das noch nicht und die planen 13.000 Satelliten.
Und noch ein zweites System, auch noch mit 15.000 Satelliten.
Und Starlink hat übrigens seine Leo-Position auch korrigiert.
Also ich glaube, die neuen Satelliten werden tiefer fliegen als die bisherigen,
was eine interessante Entscheidung ist, weil umso tiefer du fliegst,
umso mehr Sprit und umso weniger Betriebsdauer hast du ja.
Aber sie hatten das Problem, dass es zu lange dauert, dass die runterkommen
müssen, weil sie keinen Sprit mehr haben, dass die zu lange brauchen,
um versenkt zu werden und das einfach zu viel Space-Debris erzeugt.
Das wäre auch nochmal so ein Thema, aber lass uns das jetzt an dieser Stelle
nicht diskutieren. Da bin ich ja bei Raumzeit auch immer wieder mal im Thema.
Die vorletzte Sendung hat sich unter anderem mit dieser Frage beschäftigt.
Die kann ich gerne nochmal verlinken. Gut, soviel zum Starlink-Desaster für die Russen.
Das ist natürlich schon mal ein Schock und wir werden auch gleich sehen,
wie die Ukraine das ausgenutzt hat.
Aber die Russen haben sich ja dann sozusagen selber noch einen draufgelegt.
Ja, die Russen wären nicht die Russen, wenn sie nicht dort noch einen oben draufsetzen könnten.
Genau, denn das Timing könnte schlechter nicht sein. Jetzt ist es ja so,
der Default-Messenger in Russland ist Telegram.
Der Dienst ist ja auch von einem Russen, von diesem Pavel Durov mal gestartet
worden, betreibt es ja auch heute noch.
Das macht er allerdings nicht aus Russland heraus, sondern aus Dubai.
Gab es vor kurzem ja den Fall, dass er festgenommen wurde in Frankreich.
Er hat unter anderem auch die französische Staatsbürgerschaft,
da war er irgendwie in Paris, da haben sie ihn gleich festgenommen und verhört,
weil die Franzosen ein bisschen unglücklich mit dem Zugriff waren,
den sie auf entsprechende Kommunikationen hatten.
Also wenn da sozusagen Bösewichte unterwegs sind, dann gab es für die Franzosen
keine Möglichkeit, bei Telegram jemanden an die Leitung zu bekommen,
um zu sagen, was denn hier los ist.
Und dieser Mangel an Kooperation, der wurde dann behoben, indem man ihn einfach
festgesetzt hat und ihn erst wieder hat gehen lassen, als es dann eine Einigung
gab. Seitdem kommen zumindest die Franzosen da besser ran.
Ich schätze mal, die Lösung dürfte auch andere Länder glücklich gemacht haben.
Aber davon abgesehen, war es immer so ein bisschen unklar, welche Rolle Telegram
eigentlich spielt und ob Telegram nicht vielleicht doch auch mit dem russischen
Staat in einem Boot sitzt,
weil am Ende des Tages ein populärer Messenger in Russland und von einem Russen gegründet.
War immer so ein bisschen unklar sieht aber jetzt so aus, als ob die Kooperation
zumindest nicht so gut lief auf jeden Fall möchte gerne Putin,
dass die Russen kein Telegram mehr verwenden und hat Telegram schlicht abgedreht
und zwar sowohl an der Front als auch in Russland selbst,
und möchte jetzt gerne dass alle stattdessen die tolle Max App verwenden die
Russland selber entwickelt hat was auch ein ganz toller Messenger ist,
der überhaupt nicht alle überwacht und überhaupt nicht das Mikrofon einschaltet oder die Kamera.
Doch genau das tut diese App und das ist sozusagen der Versuch,
die Russen sozusagen auf so einen Einheitsmessenger zu bekommen und alle anderen
Messengers werden geblockt, eben jetzt auch Telegram.
Dazu muss man natürlich wissen, dass abgesehen von Starlink,
Telegram das Tool schlechthin ist, auch im russischen Militär,
um sich zu koordinieren.
Das heißt auch die gesamte Militärlogistik basiert auf Telegram.
Nicht nur die ganzen Blogger und Informations- und Diskussionskanäle laufen
darüber, sondern eben auch darüber was.
Das ist natürlich dann gleich der nächste Schock, das kam dann gleich hinterher,
sodass sich also die Russen einerseits darüber beklagen, dass ihnen die USA
ihre Kommunikation wegnimmt und eben jetzt die Russen sich auch selber noch
ein Bein stellen, indem sie eben Telegramm abschalten.
Inwiefern sie jetzt da die Truppen vor Ort zwingen, Max zu verwenden,
kann ich noch nicht sagen.
Auf jeden Fall dürfte das Ganze erhebliche Disruptionen auslösen und so sieht es auch in etwa aus.
Ja, und hast du da noch was zu sagen?
Ja, es hat halt in Russland bei dem Großteil der Bevölkerung für wenig Begeisterung
gesorgt und vor allem bei der jungen Generation,
die ja dann auch, gab es dann auch wieder so einer von den Bloggern,
die dann in Russland rumlaufen und Leute fragen.
So hat dann Leute gefragt auf der Straße in Moskau,
was sie denn jetzt halten von der Telegram-Blockade und ob sie denn jetzt auf Max gehen würden.
Und da war ganz klar, der Einzige,
der bereit war oder meinte, er hätte auch Max auf seinem Telefon,
war aber auch nicht begeistert, war irgendein 70- oder 80-jähriger Rentner.
So und der
meinte ja max hätte auch irgendwie aber er fand das trotzdem nicht gut dass
irgendwie die telegramm jetzt nicht mehr so richtig funktioniert also der letzte
stand von dem ich weiß dass man zwar noch textnachrichten verschicken kann aber eben keine video keine.
Videobilder, also keine Attachments irgendwie, keine Fotos, keine Videos.
Und das war wohl angeblich auch eine Funktion,
die von den Russen viel an der Front genutzt wurde,
um dann kurzerhand irgendwelche Aufklärungsvideos zu teilen oder an andere benachbarte
Truppen zu schicken oder direkt Aufnahmen von der Front, die sie gerade gemacht haben,
zurück ins Hauptquartier zu senden und so.
Das haben sie dann wohl teilweise per Telegramm gemacht.
Weil das militärische Funkequipment ist nicht auf diese Bandbreiten und Funktionalitäten ausgelegt.
Also du kannst nicht irgendwie mit, ja, also ich wüsste jetzt von keinem,
ich sag mal, Feldfunkgerät oder so,
wo du dann einfach von einem Handy, von einem Handyvideos mit verschicken kannst oder so.
Ja, gibt es nicht. Naja, was hatte das jetzt für Folgen, außer dass sich die
Russen total aufregen und das alles völlig bekloppt finden?
Das hat die Kommunikation an der Frontline natürlich komplett aufgelöst und
das scheinen die Ukrainer auch ausgenutzt zu haben.
Und zwar gab es jetzt in der letzten Woche...
Verschiedene Gegenangriffe der Ukraine. Also wir hatten ja vorhin von der Situation
an der Frontlinie berichtet und es
war halt im Wesentlichen ein Verteidigungskrieg, der hier geführt wurde.
Man hat jetzt die Russen nicht angegriffen, sondern man hat die irgendwie kommen
lassen, hat versucht ihnen so viel Schaden zuzufügen, wie es irgendwie geht.
Und wenn dann der Druck zu groß wurde, hat man sich wieder zurückfallen lassen.
Und das ist halt dieses Trading, man gibt halt Land dafür, dass man eben das
eigene Personal möglichst unschädlich hält.
Aber jetzt hat man natürlich eine Gelegenheit gesehen, diese Kommunikationsverwirrung
auszunutzen und ist davon ausgegangen,
und das scheint auch die richtige Kalkulation gewesen zu sein,
dass einfach so wenig Koordination existiert, dass man jetzt mit gezielten,
schnellen Clearing-Vorstößen, also das bewusste Einmarschieren in bestimmte
Gebiete, von dem man weiß, da sind irgendwie Russen,
dass man sich jetzt wirklich mit einzelnen Truppen vorstößt,
schnell eine Aufräumaktion startet, sprich alle Häuser durchsucht etc.
Oder eben auch schon bekannte Orte aufsucht und dafür sorgt,
dass eben diese Bereiche von russischen Truppen wieder gereinigt werden und.
Das hat stattgefunden und nach bisherigen Berichten sind wohl an die 200 Quadratkilometer
Gebiet hier wiederum zurückerobert worden.
Um das mal in Kontext zu setzen, das ist in etwa die Fläche,
die Russland im ganzen Dezember den Ukrainern abgerungen hat.
Also innerhalb weniger Tage wurde der Fortschritt der Russen von mindestens
einem Monat wieder rückgängig gemacht und das war vor allem insofern jetzt ganz erfreulich,
weil es gab zwei Schwerpunkte, wo sie sich sozusagen nach vorne getraut haben.
Das eine ist eine Region im Donbass, beziehungsweise in dem Gebiet,
wo es auch schon im Osten nach in den Bereich von Saporizhia geht.
Huleipole und so weiter, also ein bisschen südlich von den Zentren,
über die wir zuletzt so berichtet haben, wo im Wesentlichen auch nur Felder und Dörfer sind.
Also da ist irgendwie auch nicht viel zu holen, aber dort sind halt die Russen
vorangekommen und dort durften sie einfach eine ganze Menge wieder zurückgeben.
Und was noch viel wichtiger ist, am Dnipro-Becken,
dem ehemaligen, also dieses Gebiet, was ja durch die Zerstörung des Karkovka-Damms
jetzt quasi in so eine Marschlandschaft zurückverwandelt wurde,
weil dort eben nicht mehr das Wasser aufgestaut wurde.
Und dieser Bereich ist militärisch nach wie vor nicht nutzbar,
weil das ist quasi alles nur Schlamm und Moor.
Aber an der Kante davon südlich der großen Hauptstadt von Saporizia,
also Saporizia ist ja sowohl der Name der Hauptstadt der Region als auch die
Region selber, so ist das ja generell in der Ukraine.
Und südlich von der Stadt Saporizia eben an diesem ehemaligen Becken,
Staudammbecken, dort waren die Russen der Stadt schon relativ nahe gekommen.
Das ist natürlich so das Schlimmste, wenn die Russen in die Nähe einer größeren
Siedlung kommen und das dann in Artilleriereichweite gerät, dann fangen sie
ja sofort an, irgendwie die Wohngebiete zu beballern.
Und genau an dieser Stelle sieht es gerade so aus, als ob die Ukrainer die Russen
wieder signifikant haben zurückdringen können.
Also ich habe jetzt signifikant gesagt, das weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau
wie signifikant das ist, aber jeder Kilometer hilft an dieser Stelle und es
ist derzeit noch ein bisschen unklar, wie weit sie wirklich vorangekommen sind.
Das wird sich vermutlich auch erst so in der Woche wirklich abbilden.
Weil diese Maps, die es gibt, an denen man sich so grob orientieren kann,
wie der Frontverlauf ist, die werden ohnehin immer etwas zeitverzögernd angepasst,
wenn es wirklich, wirklich klar ist und in gewisser Hinsicht auch bestätigt wurde,
dass sich eben die Frontlinie entsprechend verschoben hat.
Aber solange solche Einsätze laufen, passiert da eben meist relativ wenig auf diesen Karten,
Man kann dann so ein bisschen gucken, was die Russen so behaupten auf ihren
Kanälen und wenn man danach geht, scheinen die Russen derzeit an der Frontlinie
echte Probleme zu haben durch diesen Kommunikationsausfall.
Also ich hatte gesehen, dass sie an einigen Stellen sehr weit ins Hinterland
vorgedrungen sind mit gepanzerten Fahrzeugen,
also dass ihnen tatsächlich im Prinzip ein Durchbruch dort gelungen ist einfach,
wo sie dann entlang der eigentlich russischen Transportwege,
Also wo sie dann unter den russischen Drohnenschutznetzen unterwegs waren und ja,
dort quasi wohl weit im russischen Hinterland dann auch Nachschub zerstört haben.
Das war wohl das Ziel und dadurch dann,
also sie haben jetzt nicht alle Soldaten rausgeräumt, die sich in dem Gebiet
aufgehalten haben, sondern wohl primär deren Nachschub abgeschnitten und sich
dort auch positioniert.
Und ja, damit sind halt jetzt, also sie wissen halt, dass, ja.
Soldaten ohne Nachschub gezwungen sind, dann aufzugeben, wenn ihnen Essen und Munition ausgeht.
Und,
Und da gibt es ja im Moment auch noch, das andere war das, Pokrovsk,
wo jetzt die russischen Soldaten eingekesselt sind seit Wochen.
Kopiansk.
Kopiansk, nicht Kopiansk, genau. Ja, da hatte ich jetzt gesehen,
sind wohl noch mehrere Dutzend russische Soldaten eingeschlossen,
die dann aus der Luft per Drohnen versorgt werden.
Also angeblich konnten die Ukraine 22 verschiedene Funksignale oder Callsigns
dort orten und gehen davon aus,
dass ein bisschen mehr als 22 Leute da sind, aber eben nicht viel mehr.
Also so 30, 40 vielleicht, die da in einem Block im Grunde genommen ausharren
und die Ukrainer aber offenbar sich sagen,
die sind so sehr mit dem Überleben beschäftigt, dort haben,
sagen wir, kaum genug zu essen und sterben wahrscheinlich von alleine weg oder
kapitulieren irgendwann.
Wir werden da jetzt nicht deswegen irgendwie jetzt reingehen und ja,
dort Leben aufs Spiel setzen, sondern die sind für den Moment neutralisiert
und wir hungern die jetzt aus.
Das scheint gerade die Situation dort zu sein.
Genau, so sieht es aus.
Man muss jetzt mal abwarten, was das bringt. Aber das sind auf jeden Fall gute Nachrichten.
Und von daher kann man jetzt nur hoffen, dass die Russen noch ein bisschen brauchen,
bis sie da eine Antwort finden.
Weil die müssen sich ja quasi, was ihre Kommunikation betrifft,
komplett neu aufstellen.
Jetzt ist es auch nicht so, dass sie jetzt überall Starlink zum Einsatz gebracht haben.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall ein Rückschlag und wenn es schon dazu führt,
dass die Ukraine solche Gegenangriffe starten kann, dann ist das gut.
Meine Hoffnung wäre natürlich, dass die Ukraine jetzt erkennt,
dass die Russen durch diese Gegenangriffe weiter in Unruhe bringen.
Wenn ich mich zurückerinnere an die erste große Gegenoffensive damals in Kharkiv.
Da waren ja die Russen sehr schlecht vorbereitet in der Absicherung des Hintergrundes.
Die haben zwar vorne so die Front gehabt, aber dann sind die Ukrainer,
haben halt so eine Lücke entdeckt, sind da irgendwie rein und dann war das ja
nur noch Holterdiepolter und die sind einfach mit Highspeed,
mit ihren Panzern und allem, was sie irgendwie hatten, sind sie irgendwie in
diese Region rein und haben ja innerhalb eines,
Tages irgendwie einen Riesenbereich befreit Und das ging ja dann noch so ein
paar Tage so weiter, bis die Russen es überhaupt erstmal geschafft haben,
irgendwo wieder so eine Widerstandslinie aufzubauen, wo es dann erstmal nicht weiter ging.
Und wäre natürlich jetzt schön zu sehen, dass die Logistik jetzt hier auch noch
ein bisschen weiter hinten zusammenbricht.
Allerdings mache ich mir da jetzt auch nicht zu viel Hoffnung,
denn diese Frontlinien existieren ja jetzt auch schon seit zwei Jahren.
Also diese ganzen Gebiete, von denen wir jetzt reden, haben jetzt quasi den
Gegenangriff da gesehen,
wo die Fortschritte vor kurzem stattfanden, aber die schon seit längerem existierenden
Geländegewinne der Russen, die werden sicherlich anders abgesichert sein.
Muss man abwarten, wie es läuft.
Aber generell, so habe ich von mehreren Beobachtern, die dort auch unterwegs waren, gehört.
Dass sie den Eindruck gewonnen haben, dass gerade wieder irgendwas in Bewegung
ist, dass dort ein Shift stattfindet.
Und mehr noch bei den Russen als bei den Ukrainern, aber dass die Ukrainer sich
aktuell eher ein bisschen im Aufwind befinden,
während bei den Russen, wie wir jetzt gehört haben,
sich die Probleme tendenziell häufen und sie einfach an ganz vielen Stellen
eben Lücken und Löcher stopfen müssen, personell,
finanziell, materiell, von der Motivation her.
Also es ist alles nicht Stimmung im Land, also die Heimatfront,
so sag ich mal, ist alles nicht gut.
Also wenn ich Putin wäre, wäre ich gerade nicht so gut gelaunt oder Trump.
Ja, das war ja auch sagen wir mal so ein bisschen unsere Hoffnung slash,
unsere Einschätzung, dass wir in diesem Jahr etwas Bewegungen sehen werden,
die den Status quo des letzten Jahres ein wenig aufweicht. Ob wir da schon sind, weiß ich nicht.
Das lässt sich glaube ich jetzt mit diesen kurzfristigen Änderungen so noch nicht erklären, aber,
Es kann schon sein, dass wir hier so einen Beginn eines Umschwungs sehen,
aber ich glaube, es ist noch ein bisschen zu früh, um das sicher zu sagen,
weil es von so vielen Faktoren abhängt.
Zumal ist das fast ein Wunder, wenn man bedenkt,
dass in 2025 die Unterstützung durch die USA praktisch zusammengebrochen ist für die Ukraine.
Und dass die USA,
die in 2024 noch unter Biden in derselben Größenordnung wie Europa finanziell
und sagen aber mit einem sehr,
sehr hohen Anteil auch an Waffen, Also der
Großteil der Waffen kamen aus den USA
tatsächlich für den Ukraine-Krieg
und in 2025 hat sich das auf Intelligence-Unterstützung und den Verkauf von Waffen an die Europäer,
die die dann an die Ukraine weiter gegeben haben beschränkt.
Also und.
Europa hat seine Unterstützung in 2025 um, ich glaube, rund 60 Prozent ausgeweitet.
Also hat jetzt das, was die USA gegeben haben, nicht voll kompensiert.
Es sind also nicht voll eingesprungen.
Und trotzdem hat die Ukraine es geschafft,
den Russen weiter standzuhalten und eben jetzt sogar offenbar eine kleine Trendwende
tatsächlich hinzubekommen.
Unter schwierigsten Bedingungen natürlich.
Aber ja, das finde ich doch sehr bemerkenswert.
Und du dann auch schon, glaube ich, vorhin bemerkt hattest, ja,
es mangelt an Patriot-Systemen und an anderen Dingen.
An Munition vor allem.
Also Systeme gibt es ja im Land, es könnten auch mehr sein, aber das,
was da ist, kann halt teilweise kaum betrieben werden.
Selinski hatte sich ja da geäußert und meinte, für ihn sind die schlechtesten
Tage, wenn halt irgendwie gemeldet wird, Angriffe der Russen und wir haben irgendwie
keine Munition mehr in unseren Luftabwehrsystemen.
Da stelle ich mich auch die Frage,
ob Europa hier eigentlich mittelfristig irgendwie Abhilfe schaffen kann.
Ich meine, das Patriot-System ist ja nicht irgendein System,
sondern es ist einfach das komplexeste Luftabwehrsystem der Welt und es gilt eben als das Einzige,
was wirklich eine effektive Abhilfe schafft gegen den Angriff mit ballistischen Raketen.
Also so eine Kategorie Iskander, das ist ja somit die Waffenart,
die Waffengattung der Russen, die den Ukrainern am meisten Probleme bereitet.
Nicht die einzigen, aber definitiv.
Also relativ große Langstreckenraketen oder Mittelstreckenraketen,
die sehr große Sprengkraft haben und die ballistisch fliegen.
Also die jetzt nicht wie so ein Missile, selbst angetrieben,
hin und her fliegt und auch ihren Kurs ändern kann und relativ niedrig ist und
dann gespottet werden kann und abgeschossen werden kann, sondern eben mit einem.
Also ballistisch heißt ja quasi, man schießt die los und dann fliegen sie halt
in so einer Parabel ins Ziel, können sich dabei noch so leicht korrigieren,
aber im Wesentlichen haben sie schon so eine Trajektorie.
Trajektorie und dadurch, dass sie eben dann sehr schnell abgeschossen, sehr hoch fliegen.
Fliegen die halt einfach mit einer irren Geschwindigkeit. Und in dem Moment,
wo du sie erkannt hast, ist es eigentlich schon fast zu spät.
Und da helfen halt nur Systeme, die in der Lage sind, die a.
Schnell zu detektieren und dann b.
Sehr schnell eine intelligente Abwehrrakete loszuschicken, die dann in der Lage
ist, diese Rakete in Echtzeit zu treffen, bevor sie eben ihr Ziel erreicht.
Und da gibt es eigentlich derzeit nur diese Patriot-Systeme,
die halt zu Recht Systeme heißen, weil die eben nicht nur so aus einer Batterie
bestehen, sondern man hat halt da Radare,
Kommandozentren verteilt, dann eben entsprechende Abwehrraketenstationen,
also funktionieren auch die größeren Systeme bei den Russen,
aber an die Komplexität und Intelligenz und Geschwindigkeit und Effektivität
der Patriot-Systeme kommt halt derzeit kein anderes System ran.
Und wir hatten schon über Abwehrsysteme Europas gesprochen.
Es gibt ja dieses Iris-T-System zum Beispiel, was ja auch in der Ukraine zum Einsatz kommt.
Dieses Nazams-System und zwei, drei andere europäische Systeme,
die aber eben nicht so gut sind bei der Verteidigung dieser ballistischen Raketen.
Und ich frage mich halt, ob mittlerweile nicht schon unsere europäischen Militärpartner,
daran arbeiten, da Abhilfe zu schaffen.
Ich glaube, Israel hat ja auch da was.
Ich glaube, es gibt da diverse Projekte gerade am Laufen, aber ich glaube,
man hängt das gerade auch nicht allzu sehr an die große Glocke um.
Das kann ich mir auch vorstellen.
Aber ich bin mir sicher, dass da einiges passiert.
Hatten wir eigentlich schon mal über die Oreschnik gesprochen,
weil die ja jetzt zum zweiten Mal zum Einsatz gekommen ist. ein.
Ich weiß es nicht, ob wir es erwähnt haben. Es kann sein, dass wir es erwähnt haben.
Ja, das ist ja diese Fabelrakete, mit der die Russen immer angeben,
die zwar zweimal abgeschickt wurde, aber die eigentlich nie wirklich einen Sprengsatz
hatte, sondern eigentlich immer nur so als Leerrakete geschickt wurde und dann
irgendwo gelandet ist und dann die Russen ein großes Bohai drumherum gemacht,
weil das ja so theoretisch so eine Trägerrakete auch für atomarmare Waffen sein könnte.
Und verstehen das so ein bisschen als Drohgebärde, aber ich glaube den Ukrainern
ist es auch gelungen, einen,
Abschussplatz, einen Ureschnik-Abschussplatz mit ihren Flamingo oder anderen
Raketen mal zu vernichten.
Aber da geht es immer so ein bisschen hin und her.
Was ist da eine Bedeutung?
Vor ein paar Wochen.
Und ja, es ist schon ein bisschen mehr.
Einerseits ist es eine Waffe mit 60er Jahre Technologie,
also es ist im Prinzip eine umgebaute Atomrakete mit Reichweite von ich glaube
so 8000 Kilometern oder so.
Also schon so fast eine Interkontinental-Rakete, ziemlich teuer,
irgendwie kostet ein Stück zwischen 30 und 60 Millionen oder so, das Stück.
Und die hat halt eben als Atomrakete so diese MIRVs, Multiple Independent Entry Vehicles,
also mit, ich glaube,
ich weiß nicht, acht Sprengköpfen oder so.
Und was sie jetzt bei der Oreschnik aber gemacht haben, ist,
dass die statt atomarer Sprengköpfe die Mirs mit, ich weiß nicht,
Beton oder Blei oder irgendwas gefüllt haben.
Und die dadurch quasi rein kinetische Penetratoren sind.
Das heißt, dass die zwar nicht explodieren, Aber die kinetische Energie durch
die hohe Geschwindigkeit, die diese Dinger haben.
Schon ungefähr ein Äquivalent von 500 Kilo TNT haben beim Einprall aufgrund
ihrer Geschwindigkeit.
Also die sind schon nicht ungefährlich.
Und das heißt, wenn ein Ding abgefeuert wird,
hast du halt innerhalb kürzester Zeit über ein Gebiet verteilt so sechs oder acht Einschläge, von,
ich sag mal, die so 500 Kilo Bomben entsprechen und die kommen,
es sieht im Prinzip aus fast wie ein Blitz, weil die so schnell die sind,
also ich glaube mit, ich weiß nicht, Mach 4 oder 5 unterwegs diese Dinger und du siehst,
und weil die so schnell sind, Mach 10 sogar,
sind die halt in Plasma eingehüllt,
das heißt die leuchten extrem hell das
heißt es sieht dann so aus wie im grunde genommen wie so laser einschläge erfasst
also wie sieht fast aus wie eine strahlenwaffe wenn das ganze dann kann ohne
ein schläg star boss aber.
12.300 Stundenkilometer, 3,4 Kilometer pro Sekunde.
Also es gibt nur wenige Filmaufnahmen davon, aber es sieht halt schon recht
spooky aus und die sind halt auch sehr schwer zu bekämpfen.
Allerdings, weil das wohl so alte Technologie ist, können sie jetzt auch nicht
sehr genau die Dinger steuern.
Das heißt, das ist halt im Prinzip dann wie wenn du mit einer Schrotflinte auf
ein Stadtgebiet schießt oder so mit halt einzelnen Pellets,
die dann aber 500 Kilo Bomben sind und ich weiß nicht,
ob irgendwelche der Luftabwehrsysteme in der Lage sind,
da irgendwas zu machen, Aber da kommt halt eigentlich ein Stück Metall mit Macht
10 aus dem Himmel runter und ich bin mir nicht sicher,
was man dagegen tun kann,
ob auch konventionelle Waffen irgendwie,
also wenn da, ja,
also ist nicht einfach.
Auf der anderen Seite, jetzt war das glaube ich auch nicht unbedingt auf die
Ukraine gezielt, sondern das war halt so als Warnung an den Westen gedacht,
so nach dem Motto, also es war eher so eine Demonstration.
Ja, ärgert uns nicht zu sehr oder sonst.
Ja, wir haben halt diese Oreschnik, allerdings, vielleicht noch kleines Detail.
Sie haben vorher bei den Amerikanern angerufen und den Staat angekündigt,
damit die Amerikaner nicht denken, es handelte sich um eine Atomrakete.
Aha, guck an. Ja, das war am 8. Januar. Das war genau, als wir unsere letzte
Sendung aufgenommen haben.
Dementsprechend war das jetzt sozusagen noch eine Neuigkeit und das ist dann
im Gebiet von Wiew runtergegangen.
Von daher eben sehr nah an der polnischen Grenze und dementsprechend so als,
guck mal was wir können. Aber ich meine, das Ding ist halt arschteuer und ich
glaube, so richtig viele davon haben sie auch nicht unbedingt.
Damit gewinnt man auf jeden Fall keinen Krieg.
Und wenn es ist, ist das glaube ich derzeit nicht wirklich irgendetwas,
mit dem man jetzt groß den Krieg in irgendeine Form richten kann.
Und da sind glaube ich diese Iskander-Raketen für die Russen noch von größerem
Wert und die produzieren sie ja auch irgendwie in großer Stückzahl noch und
deswegen ist das ja auch so ein Problem.
Genau, um vielleicht die Geschichte mit den Waffensystemen, die derzeit so im
Gespräch sind und die eine Rolle spielen,
noch abzurunden, kann man auch nochmal diese Flamingo-Raketen der Ukraine erwähnen,
die haben wir ja schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, das ist ja so ein bisschen die Wunderwaffe,
die eine Tonne Sprengstoff bis zu 3000 Kilometer weit tragen kann.
Man ist sich immer noch so ein bisschen unsicher darüber, wie weit das System
gedient ist in puncto Präzision.
Es gab jetzt vorgestern wieder einen Angriff auf ein...
Ein Hafen am Schwarzen Meer, da ist so eine Halle zerstört worden,
das war so direkt neben Ölsilos und man würde doch eher erwarten,
dass sie dann diese Silos zerstören und nicht diese Halle.
Es sei denn jetzt, in dieser Halle wäre irgendwas ganz Besonderes drin gewesen,
aber eigentlich war das wohl nur so für Speiseöl vorgesehen.
Also es ist immer noch ein bisschen unklar, wie da die Strategie ist.
Es gab Berichte von erfolgreichen Strikes, es gab Berichte von Strikes,
wo man sich nicht so richtig sicher war, ob Flamingos zum Einsatz kamen.
Und es gab eben solche Berichte von Einsätzen, wo es sehr nach Flamingo aussah.
Das sieht man vor allem an diesen großen Kratern, die dann später auf den Satellitenbildern
zu sehen sind, wo aber eben nicht klar ist, ob das eigentliche Ziel jetzt wirklich
getroffen wurde oder ob man nicht dann doch wieder dicht daneben war.
Also da gibt es noch so Zweifel.
Trotz alledem geht da die Produktion voran.
Selenskyj hat wohl auch oder irgendjemand anders im Militär hat wohl auch zugegeben,
dass es den Russen gelungen ist, einen Produktionsstandort der Flamingo-Raketen
zu zerstören oder zumindest anzugreifen,
sodass das eben ein wenig für Verzögerung gesorgt hat.
Aber das wird sich zeigen.
Ansonsten sind diese FP1, FP2 Drohnen sehr erfolgreich in letzter Zeit.
Die haben wir schon mal erwähnt von Firepoint, ukrainische Herstellung,
damit wird sehr viel zerstört.
Und ja, du hast da noch eine Story gehört von Veteranen, die zum Einsatz kommen.
Ja, es gab Berichte, so in der Presse,
dass wohl angeblich eine Anzahl von ehemaligen Angehörigen der Streitkräfte
sowohl der Niederlande als auch der USA,
Da, also ehemalige F-16-Piloten,
die ausgeschieden sind,
von der Ukraine angeheuert wurde oder sich haben anheuern lassen,
um Einsätze über der Ukraine mit der F-16 zu fliegen, also aktiv an Kampfeinsätzen teilzunehmen.
Es gab keinerlei offizielle Bestätigung dafür,
sondern eben nur, ja, jemand, ein Insider hat berichtet.
Und insofern, ja, gibt es da nichts Gesichertes, aber alle halten das doch fest.
Für sehr glaubhaft und zwar aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Einmal macht es total Sinn, die Hauptmissionen sind halt, es ist halt bei der
Luftabwehr, also Shahid-Drohnen abzuschießen.
Ich glaube, dass da moralisch auch wenig Leute ein Problem mit haben,
wenn jemand dort hilft, Leben zu retten.
Also sie wahrscheinlich dann ja mehr Leben retten, als dass sie vernichten.
Wobei es wenig konkrete Informationen gibt.
Aber eigentlich ist es fast ein No-Brainer, das zu tun. zumal die,
Ukraine wohl auch jetzt mittlerweile an
die 30 F-16 erhalten hat und das ist dann schon eine ganze Menge und dann ein
paar erfahrene Piloten zu haben aus dem Westen, die dann mitfliegen, die dann helfen,
die einheimischen Rookies dann auszubilden, die teilweise nur,
ich weiß nicht, sechs oder zwölf Monate Training hatten.
Also aus meiner Sicht, wenn sie es nicht schon tun, wie berichtet,
sollten sie es einfach tun.
Und ich denke mal auch, dass sie es nicht an die große Glocke hängen werden.
Und wahrscheinlich dann auch, ich denke mal, dann eingegliedert sein dürften
einfach in die ukrainische Armee.
Zumal, das hatten wir auch vergessen zu erwähnen, dass die Ukraine ihre fremden
Legionen abgeschafft hat.
Und jetzt dort deren Mitglieder, die die weitermachen wollten,
jetzt dann quasi bei der regulären ukrainischen Armee jetzt mitmachen können.
Es gibt jetzt auch noch eine neue Kooperation zwischen Ukraine und Deutschland.
Es wurde ja gerade angekündigt, dass jetzt von dem ukrainischen Unternehmen,
ich weiß nicht genau welchen oder von welcher Kooperation, aber es wird auf
jeden Fall jetzt in Deutschland von der Ukraine produziert.
Also man hat quasi jetzt einen Standort in Deutschland aufgemacht,
ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht wo,
wo halt ukrainische Drohnen produziert werden, wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal
für die Ukraine und wie ich vermute ist die Motivation natürlich einerseits,
Standort Deutschland ist natürlich jetzt erstmal ungefährdet,
derzeit von den Russen angegriffen zu werden.
Und ich würde mich auch nicht,
wundern, dass hier auch viele Ukrainer, die in Deutschland sind, dort arbeiten.
Das wäre ja auch nochmal ein interessanter Move, aber das ist jetzt nur meine Spekulation.
Auf jeden Fall passiert, da war es, es gab ja auch ähnliche Kooperationen schon
mit Dänemark und so weiter, das wird sicherlich noch weitergehen.
Ja, ja, ja. Also es gab jedenfalls eine sehr prominente Präsentation,
die dann auch aufgenommen wurde.
Ich glaube, Selenskyj war, glaube ich, auch dabei, oder?
Also ich habe gehört, dass sie
jetzt bis Ende des Jahres 10.000 Drohnen produzieren und liefern wollen.
Das klang für mich jetzt nicht nach einer allzu gewaltigen Zahl,
wobei das vermutlich ganz anständige Drohnen sind.
Aber trotzdem, ich hätte mir eher, ich sage mal, also eine Million hätte mich jetzt beeindruckt.
Ja gut, ich meine, da geht es ja dann auch erstmal darum, du musst das ja erstmal
aufbauen, du musst dann sozusagen auch erstmal eine Organisationsstruktur machen,
du musst Leute anheuern, sicherlich auch ein politisches Signal.
Das heißt ja nicht, dass das immer so bleiben wird, sondern du musst ja überhaupt
erstmal die Produktion zum Laufen bekommen und wenn du 10.000 produzieren kannst,
dann kannst du halt auch irgendwann 100.000 produzieren und wenn du 100.000 produzieren kannst,
kannst du auch eine Million produzieren und wenn du das jetzt nicht nur in Deutschland
machst, sondern vielleicht irgendwie in jedem europäischen,
Land, ich übertreibe jetzt so ein bisschen, aber zumindest an mehreren Standorten,
dann wird sich das natürlich dann auch schnell,
hochfahren lassen.
Zumal dieser Standort ja dann auch, wenn er denn mal nicht mehr gebraucht wird
für die Ukraine zu produzieren,
quasi auch ein Vor-Ort-Standort ist, um zum Beispiel für Deutschland zu produzieren
und ich glaube, das ist sicherlich etwas, was hier auch im Hinterkopf ist bei dieser ganzen Aktion.
Ja, das kann gut sein. Aber
auf jeden Fall hat sich der russische
Propagandist Solovjoff hat sich halt tierisch drüber aufgeregt irgendwie und
natürlich gleich wieder von Wehrmacht gesprochen und natürlich jetzt die Deutschen genau.
Also ich glaube, wenn der sich aufregt, dann ist alles gut.
Also umso schlechter sein Tag ist, umso besser für die Ukraine.
Ja, also allein dafür hat es sich dann wahrscheinlich schon gelohnt.
Aber will sagen, die Zahlen, also es wären ja nicht, ich sag mal,
roundabout 1000 im Monat und ja,
was 50 am Tag oder so, wenn du jetzt eine 5-Tage-Woche produzierst.
So, das ist jetzt so, geht so.
Aber vielleicht haben sie ja auch nicht die richtige Zahl genannt oder wer weiß.
Also ich fand das nur, aber es ist sicher ausbaufähig.
So, ja ich denke damit sind wir dann auch am Ende unserer Berichterstattung
angekommen für diesen Teil.
Ich wollte am Ende nochmal vorstellen ein Projekt, was die Ukraine direkt unterstützt
an verschiedenen Stellen, vor allem für die Zivilbevölkerung.
Das Projekt heißt Bravery und das ist der Kollege Chris Nickerbrocker,
der hier vor allem das Projekt repräsentiert.
Es gibt natürlich noch ein paar andere Mitstreiter.
Der ist auch regelmäßig mit dem Enno Lenze in der Ukraine unterwegs.
Also deswegen ist das hier ein bekanntes Projekt.
Hier fließt Hilfe nach Ressorn, nach Pokrofs, nach Sumi und Sven alle möglichen
Sachen dort unterstützt.
Das könnt ihr alles auf der Webseite auch selber nachlesen.
Vor allem ist es halt eine Organisation, der man was spenden kann,
die hier auch als gemeinnützig anerkannt ist.
Das heißt, ihr könnt das dann auch entsprechend absetzen.
Wenn ihr das macht, könnt ihr da gerne noch UKW in die Notizen mit reinschreiben.
Dann wissen die auch Bescheid, wo es herkommt.
Und ja, damit würde ich die Sendung abschließen. Hast du noch eine Botschaft, Pabbel?
Im Moment würde ich sagen, weltpolitische Situation insgesamt,
also was jetzt die Ukraine und die USA angeht,
habe ich das Gefühl, war zwischendurch mal schlimmer. als sie im Moment ist.
Also es ist jetzt, wir befinden uns nicht in einem neuen Tiefpunkt,
sondern ja, eher irgendwo.
Verhaltener Optimismus ist angesagt.
Verhaltener, ja, also es gibt Anlass zur Hoffnung. Lass uns mal so formulieren.
Wenn Pavel das sagt, dann soll das was heißen. Okay Leute, dann sage ich Tschüss und bis bald.
Macht's gut.